GOOD MORNING I LIKE TO CALL O
ORDER THE HEARING OF THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON PRIVACY
AND CONSUMER PROTECTION OF JULY
THIRD.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN ARE TODAY WE
HAVE A TOTAL OF THREE BILLS ON
THE AGENDA.
AND I NOTICED THAT --
SENDS THE JACKSON IS HERE WITH
US SO AT THIS TIME I'D LIKE.
TO ASK YOU TO COME UP TO PRESENT
HER BILLS WE STILL DO NOT HAVE A
QUORUM SO WE'LL JUST HAVE TO
PROCEED AS A A SUBCOMMITTEE SO
WELCOME A SENATOR JACKSON.
THANK YOU I'M MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
A I AM DELIGHTED THAT THE ISSUE
OF PRIVACY IS NOW.
TAKING THE FRONT AND CENTER ROLE
THAT IT.
SHOULD BE TAKING.
AND DOT IT'S MY PRIVILEGE TO
PRESENT.
SENATE BILL.
THREE TWENTY SEVEN WHICH SEEKS
TO CREATE A COMMON SENSE KERRY
REQUIREMENT. FOR INTERNET
CONNECTED DEVICES.
THING SUCH AS WIRELESS ROUTERS.
PURITY CAMERAS AND SMART CITY
INFRASTRUCTURE.
IT DOES SO BY DIRECTING
MANUFACTURERS OF THESE DEVICES.
TO EQUIP THEIR PRODUCTS WITH
REASONABLE SECURITY FEATURES.
YOU THINK THAT THAT WAS SORT OF
A GIVEN.
BUT THE FACT IS THERE IS
CURRENTLY NO REQUIREMENT.
THAT THEY DO THIS.
SO OUR I'D FIRST LIKE TO START
BY ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS THAT
ARE OUTLINED.
IN THE IN ALICE'S AUTHORS
AMENDMENTS AND THANK YOUR STAFF.
UP FOR THEIR DILIGENCE HERE I
THINK THERE ARE APPROPRIATE AND
HELPFUL AND WILL --
GO ALONG WAY TO ACHIEVING THE
ULTIMATE GOAL HERE AND DELIGHTED
TO ALSO HAVE THE SUPPORT OF THE
INDUSTRY TECH AND IN PARTICULAR
AND I THINK THEY'RE HERE TO
TESTIFY AS WELL --
YOU KNOW IT WE LIVE IN A BRAVE
NEW WORLD WHERE INTERNET
CONNECTED DEVICES HAVE MOVED
WELL.
BEYOND TRADITIONAL DESKTOP
COMPUTERS AND I LOOK AT THE
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE AND
I'M NOT TELLING YOU ANYTHING
THAT YOU.
DON'T ALREADY KNOW.
BUT TODAY'S ELECTRONIC DEVICES
THAT CONNECT TO THE INTERNET AND
THERE ARE APPROXIMATELY TWENTY
FIVE BILLION OF THEM.
THEY INCLUDE MICROWAVES AND
REFRIGERATORS AND HOME DEVICES.
LIKE THERMOSTATS AND SECURITY
CAMERAS UNFORTUNATELY A
SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF THESE
DEVICES.
LACK EVEN THE MOST BASIC
SECURITY FEATURES.
SUCH AS CHANGEABLE PASSWORDS AND
USER ACCESS CONTROLS.
BUT WHAT CONCERNS ME THE MOST.
OUR INTERNET CONNECTED TOYS.
AND THE RISKS THAT THEY POSE TO
OUR CHILDREN AND THIS IS WHAT.
DREW ME TO THIS ISSUE --
ORIGINALLY.
THE KELLY DAHLE.
WHICH THE COUNTRY OF GERMANY HAS
NOW BANNED AND CONFISCATED.
BECAUSE THEY ALLOWED ANYONE TO
BE ABLE TO ACCESS INFORMATION
THAT THEY WOULD GLEAN FROM
CHILDREN.
OR DIRECT CHILDREN GO TO PLACES.
WHERE THEY WOULD BE UNSAFE?
THE THE IMAGINATION AND
INVENTIVENESS OF THE HUMAN MIND
IS VIRTUALLY UNLIMITED AND THE
GOAL IS TO MAKE SURE THAT ITS
USE FOR GOOD.
AND NOT FOR POTENTIAL EVIL
[inaudible]
SO.
RESEARCHERS HAVE FOUND AS I
MENTION THAT THIS AT ALL.
HAS A SECURITY FLAW.
THAT ALLOW STRANGERS TO SPEAK
DIRECTLY TO CHILDREN VIA THE
DAHLE FROM UP TO FIFTY FEET AWAY.
INCLUDING THROUGH THE WALLS OF A
CHILD'S BEDROOM. FOR YEARS THERE
HAVE BEEN REPORTS OF STRANGERS
TALKING TO CHILDREN THROUGH
INSECURE BABY MONITORS.
RESEARCHERS HAVE ALSO INCLUDE
ARE CONCLUDED.
THE THOUSANDS OF INSECURE WEB
CAMERAS MADE BY THE CHINESE
SELECTRIC ELECTRONICS BERMAN I
CAN'T.
DO JUSTICE TO THE NAME IS SHOWN
MAY.
WERE TAKEN OVER BY HACKERS AND
TURNED INTO A BOTNET ARMY.
DURING A MAJOR CYBERATTACK IN.
TWENTY SIXTEEN THAT DISABLED THE
WEBSITES OF TWITTER SPOTIFY THE
NEW YORK TIMES IN AIRBNB.
AND I AM NOT ALONE IN THOSE
CONCERNS THE PUBLIC IS ALSO
GRAVELY AWARE OF THIS IN
SECURITY.
AND OCTOBER TWENTY SEVENTEEN
NASDAQ JAMAL TOE SURVEY FOUND
THAT. 90% OF CONSUMERS LACK
CONFIDENCE IN THE SECURITY OF
INTERNET OF THINGS DEVICES.
MOST ORGANIZATIONS 96%.
AND 90% OF CONSUMERS BELIEVE
THERE'S A NEED FOR I OR T.
SECURITY REGULATIONS AND WANT
GOVERNMENT INVOLVEMENT.
AND A HACKER CONTROLLING I O. T.
DEVICES IS THE MOST COMMON
CONCERN OF CONSUMERS.
WHILE SIXTEEN PIN WORRY ABOUT
THEIR DATA BEING STOLEN.
THESE ARE CONCERNS THAT HAS TIME
HAS EVOLVED HAVE BEEN PROVEN TO
BE ACCURATE.
I AM NOT A TECHNICAL.
I AM ON MY PHONE HYPE LAPTOP AS
MUCH AS ANYONE I SHOULD ADMIT TO
THAT BECAUSE WE'RE ALL ON THEM
TOO MUCH.
BUT I GET IT MY FACE TIME WITH
MY GRANDCHILDREN REGULARLY.
IT'S A JOY FOR ANYONE WHO --
HAS GRANDCHILDREN OF COURSE THEN
WHEN YOU SHOW UP THEY'RE NOT
PREPARED TO SEE A REAL PERSON IN
THREE DIMENSIONS BUT BE THAT AS
IT MAY.
THAT THAT WILL PROBABLY GET
FIXED AT SOME POINT AS WELL.
AND I AM AS EXCITED BY THE AS IS
THE NEXT PERSON BY NEW
TECHNOLOGICAL ADVANCES.
THAT ALLOW US TO CONNECT IN NEW
WAYS TO GIVE US ACCESS TO
INFORMATION AT OUR FINGERTIPS.
BUT I AM CONCERNED WHEN
TECHNOLOGICAL ADVANCES PROCEED
WITHOUT ADEQUATE SAFEGUARDS.
AS AMENDED THIS BILL WOULD
REQUIRE MANUFACTURERS TO EQUIP
THEIR INTERNET CONNECTED DEVICES.
WITH REASONABLE SECURITY
FEATURES BASED ON THE NATURE OF
THE MACHINE IT USE.
WHICH COULD INCLUDE SUCH THINGS
AS THE ABILITY.
CHANGE DEFAULT PASSWORDS OR
DETECT POTENTIAL HACKERS THESE
AMENDMENTS ALLOWING THREE TWENTY
SEVEN WITH ASSEMBLY WOMAN IRWIN
CHAU T. SECURITY BILL AB.
NINETEEN OH SIX WHICH THIS
COMMITTEE PASSED A COUPLE MONTHS
AGO BRINGING TOGETHER THE
ELEMENTS THE BEST OF BOTH OF
THESE BILLS.
THERE IS NO QUESTION TECHNOLOGY
HAS AND CONTINUES TO
REVOLUTIONIZE OUR LIVES.
BUT IT'S UP TO US AS POLICY
MAKERS TO ENSURE THE TECHNOLOGY
SERVES THE PEOPLE.
AND THAT SECURITY IS NOT AN
AFTERTHOUGHT BUT RATHER A KEY
COMPONENT OF THE DESIGN PROCESS.
AND HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF THESE OF THIS BILL TODAY ARE
SOME OF THE LEADERS ON THESE
ISSUES BOTH IN TERMS OF THE
TECHNOLOGY.
AND THE POLICY ASSOCIATED WITH
THEM SAMANTHA CORBIN FROM COMMON
SENSE KIDS ACTION.
EYES EMILY RUSH HERE EMILY EMILY
SH IT IS HERE YES THANK YOU --
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF CALPERS
AND ROSEMARY SHAM WITH CARS.
I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR IPHONE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OUR FIRST
WITNESS PLEASE.
I THINK THAT'S ME MISTER CHAIR
GOOD MORNING THROUGHOUT THE
CORPSMAN ON BEHALF OF COMMON
SENSE MEDIA SPONSOR OF THE
MEASURE WOULD LIKE TO THINK THE
AUTHOR AND HER STAFF FOR THIS
HARD WORK FOR THEIR HARD WORK ON
THIS MEASURE OVER THE LAST TWO
YEARS AND JUST GENERALLY ALL THE
WORK.
THAT YOU'VE DONE CHAMPIONING
PRIVACY AND SECURITY ISSUES FOR
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES.
AND COMMON SENSE MEDIA IS IN
ADVOCACY ARM OR COMMONSENSE
ACTUALLY SEES ME AS THE POLICY
AND ADVOCACY ARM OF COMMON SENSE
MEDIA AND WORKS TO ENSURE THAT
EVERY CHILD HAS WHAT THEY NEED
TO THRIVE IN A WORLD OF MEDIA
AND TECHNOLOGY.
MORE AND MORE FAMILIES ARE
WELCOMING CONNECTED DEVICES IN
THEIR HOMES FROM THE AMAZON ECHO
ONTO GOOGLE HOME TO SMART TV'S
TALKING TEDDY BEARS AND PRODUCTS
THAT ARE DESIGNED FOR CHILDREN
AS WELL AS THOSE.
AT THAT ARE NOT DESIGNED FOR
CHILDREN AND MORE OFTEN THAN NOT
AS THE SENATOR MENTIONED THE
PRIVACY AND SECURITY ARE AN
AFTERTHOUGHT IN THE RUSH TO GET
THESE PRODUCTS OUT TO MARKET --
AS CONNECTIVITY MOVES FROM
COMPUTERS AND CELLPHONES TO
EVERYTHING FROM TEDDY BEARS TO
TOASTERS WERE PUTTING MORE OF
OURSELVES AND MORE OF OUR
CHILDREN.
AT RISK THE COMBINATION OF
INSECURITY INTERCONNECTEDNESS
AND MASSIVE AND OFTEN UNEXPECTED
INFORMATION COLLECTION CREATES A
TRIPLE WHAMMY WHERE ME FOR
FAMILIES.
AND EXPERTS PREDICT THE HACKING
OF SMART DEVICES WILL ONLY
INCREASE IN COMING YEARS LEADING.
TO EVERYTHING FROM PRIVACY HARM
TO PHYSICAL RISK INDUSTRY
LEADERS THEMSELVES HAVE SOUNDED
THE ALARM THAT CONNECTED DEVICES
ARE DESPERATELY BEHIND WHEN IT
COMES TO SECURITY STANDARDS AND
NINE OUT OF TEN CONSUMERS LACK
CONFIDENCE AND THE SECURITY OF
CONNECTED DEVICES.
BY ENSURING THAT CONNECTED
DEVICES MEET BASIC SECURITY
STANDARDS APPROPRIATE TO THE
NATURE OF THE DEVICE AND THE
INFORMATION THAT THEY COLLECT S.
B. THREE TWO SEVEN ONE ACT
COMMONSENSE PROTECTIONS THAT GET
FAMILIES THE PEACE OF MIND THEY
DESERVE.
WE ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY
THANK YOU THANK YOU MUCH NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE TIME EMILY RATS
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF COW PARA
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC INTEREST
RESEARCH GROUP.
I'M LIKE SENATOR JACKSON AND
COMMON SENSE KIDS I THINK WE
CAME TO THIS ISSUE LOOKING FIRST
AND FOREMOST AT CHILDREN --
WE DO AN ANNUAL TOY SAFETY
REPORT EVERY YEAR PASSED FOR THE
HOLIDAY SHOPPING SEASON TO GIVE
PARENTS TIPS ABOUT WHAT'S ON
STORE SHELVES THAT THEY SHOULD
BE CONSIDERING --
WHEN THEY PURCHASE TOYS AND I'M
FOR THE FIRST TIME THIS PAST
YEAR WE INCLUDED INTERNET
CONNECTED DEVICES?
I'M AND TOYS AS ONE OF THE KEY
CATEGORIES THAT PARENTS SHOULD
BE I'M JUST THINKING CAREFULLY
ABOUT BEFORE BRINGING THESE
DEVICES INTO THEIR HOMES AND
MAKING SURE THAT THEY DO HAVE
SECURITY FEATURES.
I'M ONE THING THAT HAS BEEN
MENTIONED IS THAT THE FBI HAS
ACTUALLY ISSUED A WARNING --
TO PARENTS TO CONSIDER SITE
ACTED TOYS INTO THE HOME.
YEAH AND I'M IN ADDITION TO THE
MY FRANK HERE WHAT ALL.
I WISH WE HAD OUR EVENT ARE BUT
TO A SAFETY ABOUT LAST NOVEMBER
THERE WAS THE ISSUE OF THE CLOUD
PETS TEDDY BEAR --
AT ITS IS THE BEAR THAT WHERE
PIC PARENTS AND KIDS CAN SEND
MESSAGES TO EACH OTHER FROM FAR
AWAY --
THROUGH MESSAGE RECORDINGS IT
TURNS OUT THAT THE COMPANY WHO --
WAS AT A KEPT ALL THOSE MESSAGES
IN EASY TO HACK DATABASE AND TWO
MILLION RECORDINGS WERE FOUND
ONLINE.
I'M SO DID THESE ARE REALLY
IMPORTANT ISSUES FROM PIC FOR
PARENTS TO CONSIDERING CHILDREN
ALTHOUGH THIS IS NT AN ISSUE
JUST LIMITED TO PARENTS AND KIDS.
I'M I KNOW I WAS PERSONALLY
COMPELLED BY ED FRONT PAGE STORY
IN THE NEW YORK TIMES LAST
SUNDAY ABOUT HOW INTERNET
CONNECTED DEVICES CAN BE USED IN
DOMESTIC ABUSE ABUSE CASE SAYS.
I'M AGAINST --
THAT VICTIMS AND SO I THINK IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT ISSUE AND I
THINK THAT THIS BILL WILL HELP
ENSURE THAT COMPANIES ARE
PUTTING SECURITY FEATURES FIRST
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ARE IS A
VERY SHE HIM PRESIDENT CONSUMERS
FOR AUTO RELIABILITY AND SAFETY.
AND WE GREATLY APPRECIATE
SENATOR JACKSON'S LEADERSHIP ON
THIS ISSUE AND WE HAVE VERY
SERIOUS CONCERNS EVENT ECHOED BY
THE FBI AND OTHERS ABOUT THE
SECURITY PARTICULARLY MOTOR
VEHICLES WHICH THESE DAYS ARE
BASICALLY COMPUTERS ON WHEELS.
AND ESPECIALLY EASY BECOME
INCREASINGLY AUTONOMOUS IT'S
VITALLY IMPORTANT THAT THEY BE
SECURE.
AND WE'VE ALREADY HAD PROBLEMS
WITH PACKING FOR INTO ITS
CHRYSLER --
HAD TO RECALL --
MANY OF ITS VEHICLES BECAUSE
THERE WAS A FLAW THAT ALLOWED
HACKERS TO REMOTELY CONTROL THEM.
POSING IN ON PRESIDENT DANGER.
FOR NOT ONLY THOSE WHO ARE DRIVE
PASSENGERS AND OTHERS WHO SHARE
THE ROADS.
AND HACKERS COULD CUT THE BRAKES
SHUT DOWN THE ENGINE DRIVER OFF
THE ROAD OR MAKE ALL THE
ELECTRONICS GO HAYWIRE.
THERE ARE NO FEDERAL STANDARDS
UNFORTUNATELY --
REGARDING MOTOR VEHICLE SEACM
SECURITY SO IT'S UP TO THE
STATES TO ACT ON THAT.
AND WE WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT THE
FBI IS ONE THAT ECONOMIST CARS
COULD BE USED AS LETHAL WEAPONS.
AND THEY HAVE PREDICTED THAT IT
THOMAS CARS WILL HAVE QUOTE A
HIGH IMPACT ON TRANSFORMING WHAT
BOTH LAW ENFORCEMENT AND ITS
ADVERSARIES.
CAN OPERATIONALLY TO WITH A CAR --
SO WE NEED TO BE COGNIZANT OF
THAT AND I THINK ANTICIPATE
PROBLEMS BEFORE THEY GET WORSE.
AND WE WOULD GREATLY APPRECIATE
YOUR AYE VOTE FOR THIS BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY SELL ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
PLEASE STEP FORWARD.
PLEASE TELL US WHO YOU ARE AND
THE ASSOCIATION OR COMPANY THAT
YOU WITH.
SITTING ATTACK OUR CONSUMER
ATTORNEYS OF CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT PLACE.
HI --
FEELING GRIEVES WITH ADVANCED
MEDICAL TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION
WERE ACTUALLY A NEUTRAL ON THE
BILL BUT WE JUST WANTED TO COME
TO A BRIEF COMMENT.
A CYBERSECURITY SLICK BAKED INTO
ALL OF OUR PRODUCT DESIGNED
THROUGHOUT THE LIFECYCLE WE
REALLY WANT TO THANK THE SENATOR
FOR WORKING WITH US ON THESE
ISSUES OUT OVER THE LAST TWO
YEARS REALLY APPRECIATE THE
COLLABORATIVE FAT PROTEGER SHE'S
TAKEN WEEKLY WORK CLOSELY WITH
HER SO.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND I ALSO
BECOME FREE LIFE SCIENCES
SOCIAIS XIN ECHOES ARE COMMENTS.
THANK YOU MATCH NEXT PLACE --
MAUREEN HIGGINS REPRESENTING
VIACOM AYE ONE ASSOCIATE MY
COMMENTS WITH MY COLLEAGUE WE
ARE HAPPILY NEUTRAL WE WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR INNER STAFF IN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ONE FOR ALL OF
THEIR WORK ON THIS ISSUE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH JOHN
OPPOSITION.
AT THIS TIME LOTSA ESTABLISH
QUORUM.
BROKAW PLACE NO MAN'S.
CHAO HERE HIGHLY.
BAKER HERE BERMAN THERE
[inaudible]
CALDERON [inaudible]
GABRIEL [inaudible]
IRWIN [inaudible]
MULLIN [inaudible]
OBERNOLTE [inaudible]
REYES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WELCOME
OPPOSITION --
ANYTIME YOU'RE READY PLEASE
BEGIN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I'M
KEVIN MESSNER I'M WITH THE
ASSOCIATION OF HOME APPLIANCE
MANUFACTURERS --
SO ONE TO GIVE A PERSPECTIVE
FROM MANUFACTURERS BLACKS
THEY'RE GONNA HAVE TO MAKE THESE
PRODUCTS TO DEAL WITH AND WHICH
DEAL WITH SMART APPLIANCES
REFRIGERATORS.
NUMBER SMART APPLIANCES THAT ARE
OUT THERE --
AND THEN WERE HOPEFUL AND
HOPEFULLY ENCOURAGE TO TO WORK
WITH THE SENATOR --
ON THIS IS WELL WE DON'T HAVE
ANY DISAGREEMENT ON THE
OBJECTIVE.
WE WANT.
THE HOME TO BE.
A SECURE OR AND ANY WEEK WINKLE
WEAK LINK AND THE HOME --
SOME FROM SOME OTHER PRODUCT
BEING BROUGHT AND IS PROBLEMATIC
SO WE WANT IT TO BE STRONG.
OUR ISSUES ARE WITH THE WAY THE
BILL AS DRAFTED NOW.
IS THE BEST WAY TO HANDLE
CYBERSECURITY IS THROUGH.
PROTOCOLS AND PROCEDURES THAT
CHANGES THREATS AND
VULNERABILITIES OF ALL --
BUT THAT CAN BE HANDLED BESTER
NATIONAL CONSENSUS STANDARDS --
THERE THERE'S ONE OUT THERE NOW
THERE'S YOU WELL TWENTY NINE
HUNDRED THAT'S BEEN ADOPTED BY
CANADA IT SETS OUT.
RISK ANALYSIS AUTHENTICATION
PROCEDURES.
THAT'S HOW SECURITY IS DONE
[inaudible]
IT'S IT'S PROBLEMATIC WHEN IT'S
THE A VAGUE REASONABLE SECURITY
FEATURE THAT LAWYERS CAN ARGUE
ABOUT AFTER.
AND AND HINDSIGHT'S ALWAYS
TWENTY TWENTY WITH SECURITY
[inaudible]
IF.
WE'LL LOOK BACK JUST GET INTO
THE BUILDING THIS MORNING I YOU
SEE PEOPLE TAKE THEIR LAPTOPS
OUT.
THAT'S NOW.
IT'S SITTARD REASONABLE SECURITY
YOU TAKE OUT YOUR LAPTOP BEFORE
THAT IT HAPPENED IT WASN'T
REASONABLE SECURITY TAKE OUT
YOUR LAPTOP BUT YOU COULD TO
MANUFACTURE SUBJECT TO
ENFORCEMENT TEN FIFTEEN YEARS
AFTER THE FACT SANTA YOU SHOULD
HAVE KNOWN THAT.
AND SO HINDSIGHT'S ALWAYS.
TWENTY TWENTY WE JUST DON'T
WANNA BE SUBJECT THE MONDAY
MORNING QUARTERBACKING BY
LAWYERS WOULD LIKE TO HAVE
STRONG CYBERSECURITY
[inaudible]
AND WE THINK THAT WE CAN GET
THERE IF YOU UTILIZE THE BASIS
OF NATIONAL CONSENSUS STANDARDS.
I CAN GET US THERE INSTEAD OF A
VAGUE REASONABLE SECURITY.
SO WE'D LIKE TO HAVE A STRONG.
CYBERSECURITY BILL WE DON'T
REALLY ONE A JOB SECURITY BILL
FOR LAWYERS AND ENFORCEMENT
FOLKS -- AND
WE THINK WE CAN GET THERE NO WE
THINK WE GET TECHNICAL FOLKS AND
WE ALL ENDS NINE CENTER I THINK.
ONE OF HI BIG WHAT WE'RE
HOPEFUL THAT WE GET EVERYBODY IN
THE ROOM.
AND GET MANUFACTURES AND TO TALK
ABOUT HOW THINGS SHOULD BE
DESIGNED BASED ON PROTOCOLS AND
PROCEDURES.
NOT BASED ON JUST.
REGIONAL SECURITY FEATURES SO
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MATCH ANNEX WHEN HIS
PLACE.
I THINK THE CHAIRED THE
COMMITTEE OF THE AUTHOR --
BOTH SENATOR JACKSON AND IS A
MEMBER IRWIN FOR THE WORK ON THE
BILL SO FAR NOT MANY MISTRAL
COOK A REPRESENT THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION WHERE IT SOMEWHAT
UNUSUAL POSITION ON THIS BILL
AND THAT WE HAVE NOT YET TAKEN A
POSITION --
BECAUSE WE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO MEET WITH SENATOR JACKSON'S
OFFICE --
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER IRWIN'S
OFFICE STAFF YESTERDAY TO I
DISCUSS OUR ISSUES --
AND THOSE COMPANIES WERE VERY
PRODUCTIVE OUTS WERE HOPING TO
CONTINUE BUT OUT WE HAVE BEEN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED TO THE
COMPANION BILL TO SB --
THREE TWENTY SEVEN WHICH IS AB
NINETEEN OH SIX AND WE PER TO
THIS COMMITTEE WHEN IT WAS
INITIALLY HEARD --
AND BECAUSE THE BILLS HAVE
IDENTICAL LANGUAGE WE HAVE
SIMILAR ISSUES --
WITH THIS BILL FIRST --
IS WITH THE DEFINITION OF
MANUFACTURER --
IT EXPRESSLY EXCLUDES PEOPLE
THAT IMPORT --
AND RESELL CONNECTED DEVICES
UNDER THEIR OWN PRIVATE LABEL
THIS IS AN ISSUE OF FOR EXAMPLE
SENATOR JACKSON MENTIONED A
YOUNG MY CHINESE MANUFACTURER
THEY'RE ACTUALLY NOT GOING TO BE
COVERED BY THIS BILL.
AYE BECAUSE THEY ARE A CHINESE
MANUFACTURER AND THEY DO NOT
SELL THEIR PRODUCTS TO END USERS
THE ONLY WAY THAT THEIR PRODUCTS
INTO THE MARKET IS THROUGH THE
WORK --
IMPORTERS --
THAT.
IMPORTANT IS ALREADY EXISTING
MANUFACTURED DEVICES THAT THEY
DON'T CONTRACT FOR THE ALREADY
SOURCE.
THE IMPORT THEM TO THE
CALIFORNIA MARKET THEY PUT THEIR
PRIVATE LABEL ON THEM AND THEY
RESULT.
IN THE PREVIOUS ANALYSIS OF AB
NINETEEN A SIX A GOOD EXAMPLE OF
THIS IS THE COMPANY TRENDNET IN
THEIR SECURE VIEW CAMERAS --
THAT ISSUE IT'S IS CAUSED BY
THOSE IMPORT AS A RESELLER SO AS
LONG AS THE DEFINITION OF OF
MANUFACTURE EXCLUDES THOSE
PEOPLE WE CAN NEVER HAVE A TRULY
CYBER -- SHE
CYBERSECURITY BOTH GOING TO
FRUSTRATE THE PURPOSE OF THIS
BILL BECAUSE SENATORS UNSECURE
DEVICES ARE ON OUR NETWORKS --
ALL THE EFFORT THAT WE MAKE TO
SECURE OUR DEVICES ARE MOOT AYE
IT ALSO PLACES AT A COMPETITIVE
DISADVANTAGE BECAUSE THESE
PEOPLE INCREASE THEIR MARKET
SHARE -- OUR
MANUFACTURERS THAT DO THINGS BY
THESE CHEAPER UNSECURE DEVICES
BUT THE SECOND ISSUE IS THE
REASONABLENESS TEST WE BELIEVE
IT SHOULD INCLUDE OR SHOULD BE
TIED TO A BROADER --
NUMBER OF INDUSTRY STANDARDS ARE
DEVELOPED BY TWO SECURITY ENTRY
EXPERTS OR OTHER CREDITED BODIES
THAT ADDRESS --
FORESEEABLE VULNERABILITIES
RIGHT NOW THE BILL EXPRESSLY --
EXPERT MOVES LIABILITY OF
COMPANIES ADOPT PASSWORDS BUT IF
A COMPANY WERE TO ADOPT MORE
SECURE MEANS THAT A PASSWORD
IT'S STILL AN OPEN QUESTION AS
TO WHETHER OR NOT THEY WOULD BE --
LIABLE UNDER THIS BILL NOT FROM
FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE DOESN'T
MAKE ANY SENSE WE DO MORE THAN A
PASSWORD OUT WE SHOULD.
BE DEEMED REASONABLE SO UNTIL
THESE ISSUES ARE ADDRESSED WE WE
DON'T THINK THAT THE BILL SHOULD
BE -- MOVED
FORWARD BUT WE CAPITA
CONVERSATION SO FAR WITH BOTH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IRWIN OFFICE
SENATOR JACKSON'S OFFICE WE'RE
CONFIDENT THAT WE CAN RESOLVE
THESE ISSUES --
SO FOR IT AGAIN RIGHT NOW WE
DON'T HAVE A POSITION WE EXPECT
OTHER WE WILL BE OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED UNLESS IT'S A RESULT
THAT.
THANK YOU MATCH NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE --
BENJAMIN PALMER BEHALF THE
ALLIANCE OF AUTOMOBILE
MANUFACTURERS REMAIN CONCERNED
ABOUT THE APPLICATION OF MOTOR
VEHICLES GIVEN THERE'S EXISTING
NHTSA GUIDANCE ON CYBERSECURITY.
THE BILL DOES CONTAIN EGGS AND
EXEMPTION FOR CONNECTED DIVIDE
IS WHOSE DEVICES HOOFS
FUNCTIONALITY IS SUBJECT TO
GUIDANCE PROMULGATED BY FEDERAL
AGENCY THIS APPEARS TO COVER OUR
CIRCUMSTANCE BUT WE WOULD LIKE
TO WORK AND AMENDMENTS WITH THE
OTHER.
TWO RESOLVER CONCERTS.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL PLEASE
STEP FORWARD.
SEEING NONE LET'S SUFFERING A
BACK TO THE COMMUNITY QUESTIONS
MISTER OBERNOLTE.
TAKE MISTER CHAIRED A SENATOR
I'D LIKE TO START BY THANKING
YOU FOR WORKING WITH ASSEMBLY
WOMAN IRWIN --
IT'S ALWAYS AWKWARD FOR US WHEN
WE GOT TO BILLS A DEAL WITH A
SIMILAR SUBJECT MATTER THE COME
THROUGH THE COMMITTEE AND OF THE
TWO OF YOU COME UP WITH A VERY
ELEGANT SOLUTION TO THAT PROBLEM
SO THANK YOU.
FOR TAKING CARE OF THAT I'D LIKE
TO FOLLOW UP ON SOME OF THE
QUESTIONS THAT WERE ASKED BY THE
OPPOSITION ABOUT THE DEFINITION
OF WHAT A REASONABLE SECURITY
STANDARD IS.
AND I AGREE THAT THE BILL LACKS
A LOT OF SPECIFICITY IN THAT
SENSE WHAT WHAT DO YOU MEAN WHEN
YOU SAY REASONABLE.
WELL --
THREESOME WE SAY REASONABLE
INSTEAD OF PROSCRIBING ARE
PRESCRIBING IS THAT IT'S GOING
TO CHANGE.
AND IRONICALLY I USUALLY GET
YOUR THIS IS TOO STRICT AND YOU
KNOW WE CAN'T ANTICIPATE
EVERYTHING SO HE MADE IT NICE
AND BROUGHT TO THE INDUSTRY CAN
MAKE ITS OWN.
DETERMINATION AS TO WHAT IS
REASONABLE AND AND WE EXPECT IT
WILL BE DONE IN GOOD FAITH AND
THAT YOU KNOW THEY KEEP ARGUING
NOBODY KNOWS THIS WORLD BETTER
THAN WE DO.
AND THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL
ESSENTIALLY SHOWS NO THIS WORLD
BETTER THAN ANYONE THEN TAKE
THOSE REASONABLE STEPS BASED
UPON THE DATA AND THE
INFORMATION THAT YOUR PARTICULAR --
DEVICE --
GENERATES SO IT IS A IT IT
ALLOWS INDUSTRY TO COME UP WITH
THOSE.
A REASONABLE DOESN'T TAKE BEST
PRACTICES IT'S HAS REASONABLE
AND I'M HAPPY TO SAY BEST
PRACTICES --
THERE'S ALWAYS A CONCERN ABOUT
LITIGATION BUT OF THIS BILL
GIVES THOSE POWERS TO THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL SO WE'RE NOT
GOING TO SEE A WHOLE BUNCH OF
YOU KNOW LAWYERS COMING IN
SECOND GUESSING THAT'S AYE I
KNOW THAT'S SORT OF A BUZZWORD
BUT THAT'S NOT WHAT THIS BILL
DOES IT'S WHAT'S.
WHAT OF THE REASONABLE
APPROACHES TAKEN GIVEN THE
PERIOD OF TIME AND WIN WITHIN
WHICH THOSE?
EFFORTS ARE MADE AS THINGS
CHANGE AND AS THEY ARE DOING ON
A DAILY BASIS YOU'VE GOT TO KNOW
WHAT.
THE AT&T ASSAULTS ARE ARE ON
YOUR EQUIPMENT WHERE YOU'RE
VULNERABILITIES.
AND ADDRESS THEM IN THAT FASHION
SO -- THERE
IS FLEXIBILITY HERE SO THAT THE
INDUSTRY CAN ADAPT BECAUSE WE
KNOW HOW QUICKLY THINGS ARE
MOVING SO RATHER THAN HAVE IT
SET.
SO THAT YOU FIX IT IS A POINT IN
TIME.
THE INDUSTRY WILL KNOW THAT AS
THE CYBER ATTACKS AND AND THE
THE KIND OF THE CREATIVITY OF OF
THOSE WHO WANTED TO HARM TO THE
SYSTEMS ARE ONE OF VIOLATE
PRIVACY AND WANT TO TAKE OVER
THE GRID AND WANT TO TAKE OVER --
AUTOMOBILES IT'S ETRE THAT THE
THAT THE COMPANIES TO
MANUFACTURERS WILL ACTUALLY.
BE ABLE TO ANTICIPATE AND TAKE
THOSE REASONABLE STEPS WHATEVER
THEY MAY BE AS THIS WHOLE CSUS
SITUATION WHICH IS SO FLUID --
CONTINUES TO ADVANCE LEAVING IT
UP TO THE INDUSTRY. TO TAKE
REASONABLE STEPS WHAT THEY
DEFINE AS REASONABLE STEPS AND
AGAIN WE HAVE A WE WE HAVE A
IDENTIFIED THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
AS SHE APPROPRIATE AGENCY I
DON'T ANTICIPATE THAT THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL IS GOING TO
BRING LAWSUIT AFTER LAWSUIT
AFTER LAWSUIT FOR SOMETHING THAT
WAS TEN YEARS.
OLD ARE YOU KNOW WE LOOK AT THE
SITUATION AS IT EXISTS AT THE
POINT IN TIME.
WHEN THE --
NEGATIVE BEHAVIOR TOOK PLACE
THAT UNDERMINE THE INTEGRITY IN
THE SECURITY IN THE PRIVACY OF
THE SYSTEM [inaudible]
OKAY SO.
I MEAN THIS IS KIND OF THE CRUX
OF MY A LACK OF COMFORT WITH.
THE DEFINITION OF REASONABLE ON
THE BILL BECAUSE I'VE BEEN IN
THE TECH INDUSTRY FOR THIRTY
YEARS NOW.
AND ALTHOUGH I'M NOT AN EXPERT
ON CONNECTED DEVICES I KNOW
SOMETHING ABOUT THEM.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT REASONABLE
MEANS SO WHEN YOU SAY REASONABLE
TO ME THAT I'M MAKING A
CONNECTED DEVICE --
I THINK ABOUT OKAY PASSWORDS
GREAT YOU ADDRESS THAT WHAT
ABOUT ENCRYPTION DEVICE STORE
USER DATA ON THIS DEVICE IN MY
REQUIRED TO ENCRYPTED.
THAT'S POSSIBLE TO ENCRYPT THIS
IS A REASONABLE TO ENCRYPT IT I
DON'T KNOW IF I'M IF I'M
REQUIRED TO ENCRYPTED WHAT
STANDARD MY REQUIRED TO
ENCRYPTED WITH.
I IT'S NOT UNCOMMON.
IF I'M ENCRYPTING USER DATA TO
BE TO USE THE PASSWORD THAT'S
BEEN ENTERED FOR THE DEVICE AS
TO THE POPE THE KEY FOR THE
PRIVATE KEY FOR ENCRYPTING.
THE DATA ON THAT DEVICE AYE YOU
HAPPEN TO FIND ANY.
ANNE --
LIMITATIONS ON HOW LONG IT HAS
TO BE YOUR MONEY.
DIFFERENT TYPES OF CHARACTERS IT
HAS TO HAVE SO I MEAN I'M JUST
I'M NOT.
I'M NOT GONNA TRY TO CAUSE
PROBLEMS FOR HIM JUST SAYING
THAT YOU KNOW THESE ARE THE KIND
OF THINGS THAT IF I'M MAKING A
CONNECTED DEVICE I NEED TO KNOW
THAT STUFF.
AND I I HAD THE UNUSUAL.
THE EXPERIENCE LAST YEAR OF
READING EIGHT COURT TRANSCRIPT
OF A ROOM FULL OF LAWYERS
ARGUING ABOUT A BILL THAT I HAD
PASSED TWO YEARS BEFORE AND THEY
WERE TALKING ABOUT.
WHAT WAS THE INTENT OF THE
AUTHOR WILL THE AUTHOR CLEARLY
INTENDED TO DO THERE'S NO WE
DIDN'T?
AND I'M THINKING I'M THE AUTHOR
YOU COULD ASK ME IF YOU WANT TO
KNOW WHAT MY INTENT WAS PUT ARE
MADE IT ILLUSTRATES THE POINT
THAT WHAT WE DO HERE REALLY
MATTERS THE WORDS WE USE IN THE
BILL.
REALLY MATTER BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE
GOING TO ARGUE ABOUT IT AND I
WOULD JUST IF IF WE'RE GOING TO
REQUIRE THIS KIND OF SECURITY.
FOR CONNECTED DEVICES I THINK WE
OWE IT TO EVERYBODY. TO BE VERY
CLEAR ABOUT WHAT IT IS WE'RE
REQUIRING CANNOT JUST LEAVE IT
OPEN TO INTERPRETATION.
WELL I APPRECIATE THAT THE
PROBLEM IS AT IF WE FIX WHAT IT
IS THAT WE EXPECT THEM TO DO IN
TWO WEEKS THE OF THE THE ENTIRE
TECHNOLOGY MAY HAVE SHIFTED.
AND SO WHAT WE'RE DOING IS
GIVING THE THE INDUSTRY WHICH
KNOWS AND KNOWS BEST HOW TO
PROTECT.
THE INFORMATION TO OUR USE THAT
KNOWLEDGE TO PROTECT THE
INFORMATION.
THAT'S BASICALLY WHAT WE'RE
DOING IS SAYING LOOK FOLKS.
THERE ARE CERTAIN EXPECTATIONS
WE HAVE.
THAT YOU'RE GOING TO PROTECT
THIS INFORMATION YOU USE
WHATEVER REASONABLE TECHNIQUES
YOU HAVE TO DO THAT [inaudible]
AND AGAIN IF A PASSWORD IS
LOCATED DAY IN TWO WEEKS A
PASSWORD WON'T BE THE ANSWER
[inaudible]
AND BUT NO ONE'S GOING TO KNOW
THEY'RE BETTER THAN THE INDUSTRY
SO -- ARE
I'M YOU KNOW I'M HAPPY TO TALK
ABOUT OF REDIFF OR OR NARROWING
OR SPEED BEING MORE SPECIFIC
WITH THE DEFINITIONS BUT I WOULD
SUGGEST.
THAT THE MANUFACTURERS KNOW NOW
WHAT [inaudible]
THE PUBLIC.
ISN'T LIKELY TO KNOW FOR AWHILE
BECAUSE THEY ARE AT THE CUTTING
EDGE AND WE WANT THEM TO BE ABLE
TO TAKE THE REASONABLE STEPS TO
PROTECT THAT INFORMATION.
AND GIVING THEM A WIDE BERTH --
MAKES IT POSSIBLE TO GIVE THEM
AND THEIR CREATIVE --
KNOWLEDGE THE ABILITY TO DO THAT
SO -- AGAIN
YES YOU KNOW WE ALWAYS SAY IF
YOU GET TO LAWYERS A ROOM YOU
GET FOUR OPINIONS BUT AT IT YOU
KNOW THAT.
A AGAIN WE'RE LEAVING TO THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL TO EVALUATE
EXACTLY --
WITH ALL DUE RESPECT TO MY OUR
NEW COLLEAGUE HERE I'M
RECOVERING MYSELF ON THE
PROFESSION SO --
OF IT AS I KNOW SOME OF THE
OTHER MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE
ARE BUT THE THE THE BOTTOM LINE
IS WE WANT THE INDUSTRY TO BE IN
THE FOREFRONT OF THIS NOT TO BE
PRO SCRIPTED.
AS TO WHAT THEY CAN DO BUT TO BE
ABLE TO BE INVENTIVE AND
CREATIVE IN WHAT THEY CAN DO
BECAUSE THEY KNOW BETTER NINETY
ONE WHAT'S DOWN THE ROAD WHAT'S
COMING IF I COULD MAKE A
SUGGESTION.
SURE I THINK THAT ONE OF THE
POINTS THE OPPOSITION RAISED WAS
AN EXCELLENT ONE WHICH IS THAT
IF.
IF WORKING FOR A WITH WE WANT TO
BE SPECIFIC.
ABOUT WHAT WE MEAN BY REASONABLE
THEM THEIR WAYS TO DO THAT WE
PICK AN INDUSTRY STANDARD AND
THAT STANDARD IS MAINTAINED BY
INDUSTRY.
AND AS EXPECTATIONS OF SECURITY
CHANGE OVER TIME THE STANDARDS
CHANGE OVER TIME YOU REFERENCE
THAT STANDARD YOU SUCK A LOOK
THAT'S THE BASELINE YOU HAVE TO
DO AT LEAST.
AS GOOD AS THAT AND THAT'S THE
WAY THAT YOU SOLVE THAT PROBLEM
IT'S A WAY THAT WE'VE SEEN HAVE
PROBLEMS ALL THE OTHER BILLS
THAT HAVE MOVED.
THROUGH HERE SO --
BECAUSE OF MY CONCERN ALL
RESPECT TODAY BUT I WOULD
ENCOURAGE YOU MOVING FORWARD AS
YOU TALK WITH THE OPPOSITION
THAT THAT'S A REALLY ELEGANT
SOLUTION. TO TO MAKE SURE THAT
WORK WERE BEING DEFINITIVE.
AYE AND SPECIFIC ABOUT WERE
REQUIRING WHEN WE PUT THIS KIND
OF REGULATION ON INDUSTRY.
WELL LET ME JUST SUGGEST YOU
THAT THIS IS THE SAME STANDARD
THE SAME STANDARD OF
REASONABLENESS THAT HAS WORKED
IN CALIFORNIA'S DATA BREACH BILL.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND THREE SO
BASICALLY WE ARE USING A SYSTEM
AND A PROCESS THAT'S BEEN IN
PLACE AND BEEN AFFECTED FOR THE
LAST FOURTEEN YEARS.
I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT WHEN
WE PUT A REQUIREMENT OUT THERE
THE PEOPLE KNOW WHAT WEIGHT IS
WERE RIGHT OR THANK YOU FOR THE
DIALOGUE THANK YOU AND AND I
WOULD SUGGEST THAT THE CAP GIVEN
THE FACT THAT THE THIS HAS BEEN
IN PLACE.
WITH THE OF THE DATA BREACH
PROVISIONS STAT THE INDUSTRY
KNOWS.
A AND THAT THAT THAT THEY HAVE
BEEN ENCOURAGED TO APPLY USING
THAT TERMINOLOGY BUT I CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE YOUR CONCERN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OUT AND LETS
GO TO MISS REYES FOLLOWED BY HIS
BAKER.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AT SENATOR I
DO WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD.
AND I APPRECIATE TWO THINGS ALSO
MOST ESPECIALLY ONE IS YOUR
INVOLVEMENT WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
IRWIN.
IN BRINGING THIS FORWARD
TOGETHER AND THE OTHER IS IN
LISTENING TO THE OPPOSITION.
IT'S CLEAR THAT YOU'VE HAD
DIALOGUE WITH THEM THAT THEY
RECOGNIZE THAT THE DIALOGUE
CONTINUES.
AND THAT'S ALWAYS SO IMPORTANT
IN TRYING TO REACH AS AS MY
COLLEAGUE FROM BIG BEAR HAS
TALKED ABOUT.
HAVING THOSE DISCUSSIONS TO
FINALLY GET TO THE END RESULT
APPRECIATE ALL OF YOUR IN PUT IN
ALL OF YOUR WILLINGNESS TO
DISCUSS THIS.
WITH OPPOSITION AS WELL AS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ONE THANK YOU
FOR OFFERING THIS THANK YOU
APPRECIATED PASSED BAKER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
SENATOR I I SUPPORTED ARE GOOD
COLLEAGUE FROM VENN TOURISTS
BILL --
BEFORE THEY DID RAISE SOME OF
THE SAME CONCERNS AND HOPE THAT
YOU WILL REALLY WILL CONTINUE TO
FOCUS ON THEM MISTER OBERNOLTE
HAS ARTICULATED THAT WHILE I
THINK THE OPPOSITION HAS.
YES OTHER REASONABLE STANDARD
FULLY RECOVERED ATTORNEY AT AYE
I MAY NEVER RECOVER FROM THIS
YEAR SPLIT.
OF THEIR REASONABLE THE STANDARD
HAS ITS PROS AND CONS BECAUSE
WHAT IT MEANS IS YOU DON'T GET
TO LIST IT SO FACT INTENSIVE YOU
DON'T GET TO ESTABLISH IT UNTIL
YOU'RE IN A COURT.
WHICH IS VERY EXPENSIVE AND
WHILE WE WANT INDUSTRY TO BE AS
YOU SAY RIGHTLY SO.
APPRECIATE HEARING IT --
INNOVATIVE AND CREATING ITS WEEK
THIS IS EXACTLY THE TYPE OF
STANDARD THAT CAN ALSO
COMPLETELY IMPAIR THE ABILITY TO
DO THAT BECAUSE THEY DON'T KNOW
WHAT IS SUFFICIENT SO.
I EYEING WHO'S ALSO ENCOURAGE
THAT VISITING WITH A FURTHER
WITH THE OPPOSITION ABOUT THAT
AND THE POSSIBILITY OF A
NATIONAL STANDARD YOU CAN EAT
YOU CAN POINT TO IT --
IF YOU SAY REASONABLE S. YOU
KNOW INCLUDING I'M GOING TO TRY
TO MEND YOUR BILL HERE INCLUDING
NATIONAL STANDARDS YOU YOU MAY.
BE GIVING GUIDANCE TO THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL BEYOND WE JUST
WANT YOU TO GO DO THIS AND THAT
IT'S IT'S ONE POTENTIAL PLACE
IT'S ALMOST LIKE A SAFE HARBOR
THAT IS. ONE THAT CONTINUES TO
MOVE FORWARD I I WOULD STRONGLY
ENCOURAGE THAT BUT I ALSO AM
HATE EXPRESSED CONCERN.
IN THE PAST AND WANT TO AGAIN
ABOUT THE MANUFACTURING
DEFINITION.
BECAUSE WE ARE IF I REMEMBER
CORRECTLY --
FOR READING THIS.
LOOKING AT THE POSSIBILITY THAT
THAT WILL ONLY APPLY TO
DOMESTICALLY PRODUCED PRODUCTS
AND LEAVE.
THE INTERNATIONAL MARKET OUT
WHICH IS NOT ONLY A LOOPHOLE
THAT DISADVANTAGES ARE
CALIFORNIA COMPANIES AND
EMPLOYEES SO CAN YOU SPEAK TO
THAT PARTICULAR SHOW ABSOLUTELY.
THE DEFINITION OF MANUFACTURER
AND IT IS SOFT --
IN THE BILL ITSELF UNDER.
OF SEVENTEEN NINETY EIGHT POINT
NINETY ONE POINT O. TO SEE.
MANUFACTURER MEANS THE PERSON
WHO MANUFACTURERS OR CONTRACTS
WITH ANOTHER PERSON TO
MANUFACTURE.
THAT SHOULD INCLUDE THE FOLKS
FROM CHINA.
BECAUSE WE THEN CONTRACT WITH
ANOTHER PERSON.
WHO MANUFACTURES ON THAT
PERSON'S BEHALF CONNECTED
DEVICES THAT ARE SOLD OR OFFERED
FOR SALE IN CALIFORNIA?
THAT SO I I WOULD RESPECTFULLY
DISAGREE WITH THE VIEW THAT WE
ARE ACCEPTING FOREIGN COMPANIES
THEY A CONTRACT. TO MANUFACTURE
AND THEY WOULD BE INCLUDED.
AND THE LONG ARM STATUTE
CALIFORNIA WOULD ALSO GET THEM
ANYWAY.
BUT IT DOES SPECIFICALLY SAY --
CONTRACT TO MANUFACTURE SO IT
WOULD INCLUDE ALL FOREIGN
COMPANIES THAT ARE MANUFACTURING
THESE DEVICES.
BRING THEM TO THE UNITED STATES
ARM OF WHETHER IT'S UNDER THERE
THEIR NAME OR THE NAME OF AN
AMERICAN COMPANY THEY STILL ARE
INCLUDED UNDER THIS PROVISION.
THANK YOU IF I MAY.
THREE IS THE CHAIR IF I'M JUST
CURIOUS IF THANK YOU MAY ASK
THEIR OPPOSITION IS YOU'VE
LOOKED AT THAT LANGUAGE IS WELL.
IN ADVANCE YOU INTO TOO MUCH OF
A DEBATE BUT I I'VE THIS
CONCERNS ME SO I WONDER IF YOU
COULD FIND OUT WHERE WHERE'S THE
HOLE IN THAT FROM.
SO IT WOULD BE THAT THE NEXT
PART OF THAT DEFINITION WORD IT
SAYS THE FOLKS THAT ARE.
CREATE AKON TRACK TO PURCHASE
EXISTING GOODS ARE EXPRESSLY
EXCLUDED FROM THE DEFINITION
MANUFACTURER SO THE LOOPHOLE
THAT IT CREATES BETWEEN LIKE A
COMPANY LIKE JOHN BY IN A
COMPANY LIKE TREND THAT.
IS THAT A CHINESE MANUFACTURED
THE DOESN'T AUTHORIZE ANYTHING
FOR SALE OUTSIDE OF CHINA A
CREATES A BUNCH OF SAY WEBCAMS.
IN CHINA --
THEN A COMPANY THAT ESTABLISHES
ITSELF IN CALIFORNIA BEEN FINDS
THOSE DEVICES THAT EXISTS AND
CREATES A CONTRACT FOR PURCHASE
WAS WHICH IS EXPRESSLY EXCLUDED
IN THE BILL --
TO IMPORT THOSE DEVICES INTO
AMERICA THEY PUT THEIR LABEL ON
THE MISS TRAINING THAT THEY SELL
THEM TO OUR MARKETPLACE SO.
THE INTERPLAY BETWEEN THESE TWO
DIFFERENT COMPANIES IS WHAT
CREATES THE LOOPHOLE THANK YOU
AND IF IT SINCE IT SOUNDS CENTER
YOU AGREE IN THE IDEA YOU WANT
MAKE SURE GETS ABSOLUTE --
IF THERE'S ANY FURTHER
CONVERSATIONS TO FINE TUNE THAT
I HOPE YOU'RE OPEN TO THAT --
BECAUSE I I I I HOPE WE CAN --
THE FIRST TIME INSTEAD OF
INADVERTENTLY HAVE A LOOPHOLE
THAT WE KNOW.
INTERNATIONAL COMPETITION WILL
FIND A WAY AND WHERE
DISADVANTAGED CALIFORNIANS AND
RIGHT I'VE.
ONE ADDITIONAL ONE AND THAT IS
THAT ALSO.
THE CONCEPT OF HINDSIGHT SO
SOMEBODY BUYS A REFRIGERATOR
YEAH I'M I GOT A FIFTEEN YEAR
OLD REFRIGERATOR IN MY HOUSE.
AND WHAT CONTINUING DUTY THERE
IS AFTER I'VE PURCHASED.
A SOMETHING WITH THE TECHNOLOGY
AND WITH OF WHAT WAS AT THE TIME
WHAT CONTINUING DUTY MIGHT
REMAINS FOR THE MANUFACTURERS
[inaudible]
LIABILITY.
WELL THE WAY THIS BILL IS OF
WRITTEN.
THE THE QUESTION THE
MANUFACTURER'S RESPONSIBILITY.
ARM IN TERMS OF SECURITY IS AT
THE POINT THAT THE THAT THE
DEVICE WAS PURCHASED.
WE'RE NOT REQUIRING THAT THEY
ANTICIPATE FIFTEEN YEARS DOWN
THE ROAD.
ABOUT WHAT'S SECURING WHAT ISN'T
SECURE --
FIFTEEN YEARS LATER.
SO IT'S JUST IT NOW IF.
TRYING TO THINK OF A
REFRIGERATOR FIFTEEN YEARS AGO I
DON'T THINK IT'S THEY WERE VERY
AS YOU ARE THEY JUST KEPT THINGS
CLEARLY HANG ON YEAH YEAH YEAH --
SO YEAH I MEAN THEY DID THE JOB
THAT I THINK WE EXPECTED WHICH
WAS TO KEEP THE BEER COLD AND
THE ICE FROZEN --
IT TODAY OF COURSE THEY DO A LOT
OF OTHER THINGS AND SO IF YOU
WERE TO BUY ONE TODAY THE NEXT
WHEN YOU BUY TODAY UNDER THIS
BILL.
IT WOULD HAVE TO HAVE THE
SECURITY PROTECTIONS THAT ARE
AVAILABLE TODAY I THAT ARE KNOWN
TO THE MANUFACTURER.
IN AND YOU KNOW THAT THING THAT
THAT THEY KNOW ARE ARE POTENTIAL
PROBLEMS TODAY APPRECIATE THAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH [inaudible]
ANY.
MR WENT GO AHEAD PRESS THANK YOU
KNOW AND I APPRECIATE A OF
WORKING WITH YOU ON THIS BILL
AND ARE --
THAT WE'VE GONE THROUGH A LOT OF
THESE ISSUES I I'M SORRY THAT I
WALKED IN A LITTLE LATE SO I
DON'T REMEMBER I DON'T KNOW IF
ALL THIS WAS MENTIONED BUT AS
FAR AS AND THERE IS IN THE BILL
IF THERE ARE FEDERAL STANDARDS
SO.
YOU HEARD I I HOPE THAT DIVIDE.
MANUFACTURERS IF THERE ARE
FEDERAL STANDARDS YOU ARE
EXEMPTED FROM THIS BILL.
A THE SECOND THING IS WHEN WE
HEARD THIS IN PRIVACY THE
MANUFACTURERS DID EXPLAIN.
OR EXPRESS IT AND CONCERNED
ABOUT TO ADD THIS DISADVANTAGING
CALIFORNIA COMPANIES WE DID
CHANGE THE LANGUAGE AFTER
PRIVACY --
TO TO REALLY ADDRESS THAT ISSUE
AND IF IT'S STILL NOT CLEAR WILL
LOOK AT IT SOME MORE BUT
CERTAINLY THAT WAS THAT WAS
NEVER THE INTENTION TO
DISADVANTAGE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND AND I WILL
REITERATE AGAIN --
LIKE I DID AND PRIVACY AND IN
FRONT OF YOUR COMMITTEE THAT WE
HAVE BEEN WORKING ON THIS BILL
SINCE.
LAST FALL AND IT HAS GONE
THROUGH MULTIPLE MULTIPLE --
AND I HAVE VERSIONS TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE ADDRESS THE CONCERNS OF
GROUPS LIKE THE INTERNET
ASSOCIATION CAL CHAMBER --
TECHNET AND MOST OF MOST OF
THOSE ORGANIZATIONS ARE ALL OF
THEM EXCEPT --
FOR THE MANUFACTURERS ARE EITHER
NEUTRAL OR IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL SO AND WE HAVE CERTAINLY
TRY TO MAKE THIS A VERY VERY
COLLABORATIVE EFFORT AND AGAIN --
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT THAT IT IN
MY OPINION THAT WE PASSED
SOMETHING THAT STARTS TO AT
LEAST REGULATE SOME OF THESE AYE
OTA DEVICES BECAUSE WE HAVE SEEN --
WITHOUT REGULATIONS THAT WE HAVE.
YOU KNOW AN INCREDIBLE PROBLEMS
AND TO WHOM WE CAN LOOK AT
THINGS LIKE THAT THE BIG --
TAKEOVER OF DYING WARY YOU'RE
BRINGING DOWN PART OF THE
INTERNET BECAUSE YOU DON'T HAVE
APPROPRIATE SO I'M SECURITY ON
THESE AYE OF TWO DEVICES I THINK
THIS IS NOT A HUGE STEP THIS IS
A SMALL STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION SO I'M.
DEATHLY IN SUPPORT OF AND WHAT
THE SENATE DOING AND I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH --
THE LAST FEW HOLD OUTS BUT AGAIN
IF THEY WANT A FEDERAL STANDARD
THEY WOULD BE EXEMPTED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
GABRIEL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I JUST
WANTED TO COMMEND THE SENATOR
AND ALSO MY COLLEAGUE FROM
THOUSAND OAKS I THINK THIS IS A
REALLY IMPORTANT ISSUE I'M GLAD
TO SEE THIS --
THIS LEGISLATION MOVING FORWARD
I DID JUST. FOR MY OUR COLLEAGUE
FROM BIG BEAR I THINK --
YA I CERTAINLY HEAR WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING ABOUT THE THE
REASONABLENESS STANDARD I THINK
THAT -- YOU
KNOW WHEN YOU HAVE SOMETHING
LIKE THIS THAT A THAT A
MANUFACTURER IS GOING TO BE IN A
POSITION WHERE THEY'RE GONNA
HAVE THE RIGHT INCENTIVES TO DO
THE RIGHT THING THEY'RE GONNA
KNOW THEIR TECHNOLOGY.
BETTER THAN ANYBODY ELSE THEY'RE
GONNA SASS LITIGATION RISK
REPUTATIONAL RISK LOOK AT WHAT
OTHER FOLKS INDUSTRIES ARE DOING
AND THEN MAKE A REASONED
DETERMINATION.
AND I SUSPECT ALSO THAT THERE
MAY BE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
DIALOGUE WITH THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL OR ANY OTHER ENFORCEMENT
AUTHORITY IF THERE ARE CONCERNS
ABOUT.
THE STANDARD THAT THEY'VE
EMPLOYED BUT BUT AT THE END OF
THE DAY --
IF WE FIND OUT THAT THAT
STANDARD IS UNWORKABLE FOR SOME
REASON OR IS CAUSING A LOT OF
CHALLENGES ARE STIFLING
INNOVATION THERE IS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO COME BACK
AND CORRECT THIS LEGISLATION IT
SOUNDS LIKE.
THE THE AUTHOR AND AND AND MY
COLLEAGUE FROM ON THOUSAND OAKS
HAVE BEEN VERY THOUGHTFUL ABOUT
THEIR APPROACH HERE THAT THEY'VE
TALKED WITH FOLKS IN INDUSTRY SO.
IT SEEMS TO ME TO MAKE SENSE TO
MOVE FORWARD TO CHECK TO MAKE
PROGRESS IF THERE ARE LITTLE
TWEAKS THAT WE NEED TO MAKE WE
CAN ALWAYS COME BACK AND DO THAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IF THERE ARE
NO FURTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
I WANT TO THANK THE SENATOR FOR
BRINGING THIS.
LEGISLATION FORWARD I REMEMBER
JUST A FEW YEARS AGO MY SELECT
COMMITTEE HAD <c.green> --</c>
WORKSHOP ON IOTV INTO --
AT THE UC BERKELEY ONE OF THE
ONE OF THE ISSUES THAT THAT KEPT
COMING UP WAS.
THE OF THE THEORY OF OUR PRIVACY
AND SECURITY BY DESIGN AND ON
DODD IS THE CONCEPT THOUGH
WHEREBY ON THESE PRIVACY AS WELL
AS SECURITY ISSUES WERE CONSIDER
AT THE GET GO FROM THE DESIGN
PHASE.
AND OTHER BUT THIS BILL AS WELL
AS A NINETEEN OH SIX ARE YOU
KNOW REALLY HAVE THAT CONCEPT IN
MIND AND I THINK GO WHEN WE
PASSED THE BILL I THINK WE'LL.
HAVE LA TREMENDOUS IMPACT ON THE
ON THE ON THE UC DESIGN PHASE ON
ON MANY OF THESE DEVICES SO I I
I I YOU KNOW TREMENDOUSLY I WANT
TO THANK YOU AND I MISS IRWIN.
FOR A WORKING ON THIS ON THIS SO
LEGISLATION AS WELL AS A
RECOGNIZE RECOGNIZING THE
POTENTIAL CYBER THREATS UP
OPPOSED BY THESE --
DEVICES AND ALSO ONE OF COMMAND
TO BOTH OF YOU ARE ON A
RECONCILING YOUR LANGUAGES AS
WELL AS WORKING WITH
STAKEHOLDERS I KNOW IT'S BEEN
ARE YOU DON'T HAVE A LONG
PROCESS SO I WANT TO THANK YOU.
AND THEM SO WITH THAT I WANT TO
ASK YOU TO CLOSE OUR AND IN OUR
LAST -- FOR
A MOTION TO MOVE YOUR BILL.
FOR YES AND I WANNA <c.green> THANK</c>
ALL MEMBERS WHO GOOD DISCUSSION --
I THINK YOU KNOW WHAT THE GOAL
IS HERE NO ONE'S TRYING TO DO A
GOTCHA.
WITH.
IT'S NEED THEIR PRIVACY
PROTECTIONS A AGAINST THINGS
LIKE --
HACKING THAT WE'VE HAD NOT ARE
NINE ELEVEN SYSTEMS CONSTANTLY
BEING HACKED PIECE OF THE
SYSTEMS THAT WE AS THE PUBLIC
RELY UPON. FOR FOR SAFETY TO GET
IMMEDIATE RESPONSES IN
INFREQUENTLY LIFE THREATENING IN
DANGEROUS SITUATIONS.
THEY THERE'S BEEN HACKING OF OUR
AIR TRAFFIC CONTROLS A CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE LIKE OR NAT A
NATURAL GAS PIPELINE SYSTEMS
THESE HAVE ALL BEEN HACKED.
YOU KNOW THEIR PEOPLE --
PAUL ALL OVER THE WORLD WHO.
WISH TO DO US HARM AND WHO HAVE
NOTHING THEIR TASK THEY'RE PAID
BY THEIR GOVERNMENTS OR THEIR
THESE OF THE THUGS WHO IF YOU
WILL THESE GANG CENTER OUT THERE.
ATTACKING ARE VERY VULNERABLE --
SYSTEMS AND THAT THE GOAL HERE
IS TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC THE
GOAL HERE IS TO REAFFIRM THE
RIGHT THE THE EXPECTATION OF
PRIVACY.
AS YOU SAY STARTING IN THE
DESIGN CONCEPT YOU KNOW THAT
THAT THE CREATIVITY OF THE HIT
AND CAN THE HUMAN MIND IS REALLY
UNLIMITED BOTH FOR GOOD AND FOR
EVIL.
AND SO THE GOAL HERE IS TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE AS POLICY MAKERS
ARE PROTECTING THE PUBLIC AND
ARE ALSO WORKING WITH THE
VARIOUS COMPANIES WHO HAVE THAT.
A AUGUST RESPONSIBILITY TO MAKE
SURE THAT --
THEY ARE ABLE TO IMPLEMENT THESE
GOALS AND DO IT IN A WAY THAT IS
BENEFICIAL TO EVERYONE.
US SO I I WAS STRUCK BY THE
NOTION THAT COMPANIES WILL
EVALUATE THE TECHNOLOGY OF THE
REPUTATIONAL AND LITIGATION
RISKS THIS IS SORT OF THIS THIS
LEGISLATION THIS EFFORT.
IS TO PUT EVERYBODY IN A
POSITIVE POSITION SO THAT THEY
THEIR OUR PRIVACY RIGHTS.
ARE BEING PROTECTED THAT THE
MANUFACTURERS ARE IN THE
FOREFRONT TO NAFTA WHICH
REPUTATION WE I THINK IT'S AN
ADVANTAGE WHEN.
WHEN WORSE ALL AFRAID 90% THE
PUBLIC IS OF AFRAID OF THE
TECHNOLOGY AND THE POTENTIAL
EXPOSURE ASSOCIATED WITH THESE
PRODUCTS?
IT'S IN EVERYBODY'S BEST
INTEREST UP TO PASS LEGISLATION
LIKE THIS I WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS
MY COLLEAGUE FROM THOUSAND OAKS --
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT IS I
THINK CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
MOVING FORWARD IN A WORLD THAT
WE YET DO NOT KNOW.
AND WITH THAT I WOULD ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE FAKE.
BILLS AND MOVED TO HAVE A SECOND.
OF THE RECOMMENDATION IS TO PASS
TO SENATE APPROPRIATIONS.
AS AMENDED DOUBTS TOO MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL RAIL
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS CHAO
HIGH CHAO AYE KILEY.
KILEY NOW BAKER.
BAKER AYE BERMAN [inaudible]
CALDERON.
CALDERON AYE GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE MULLIN.
OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE NO RADIUS.
RADIUS I YOUR BILL IS OUT SIX TO
TWO THANKFULLY TO LOWER MEMBERS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THAT BRINGS SAYS TO S. B. ELEVEN
TWENTY ONE SENATOR DODD WELCOME.
GOOD MORNING GOOD MORNING PLUGS
AND SHARE MEMBERS LAST WEEK AB
THREE SEVENTY FIVE WAS SIGNED
INTO LAW.
THE LANDMARK THIS LANDMARK LAW
AND PROVIDES THE COUNTRY'S
TOUGHEST PRIVACY PROTECTIONS.
A PROUD CO AUTHOR OF THAT
MEASURE WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHAO.
WHICH INCLUDED MANY PROVISIONS
FROM MY ORIGINAL S. B..
ELEVEN TWENTY ONE BECAUSE AB
THREE SEVENTY FIVE A SUCH A
COMPREHENSIVE INTERNET PRIVACY
AND DATA BREACH PROTECTION LAW
THAT WAS PASSED IN A VERY SHORT
DEADLINE.
THEIR TECHNICAL FIXES THAT NEED
TO BE MADE.
S. B. ELEVEN TWENTY ONE WILL BE
AMENDED. TO BE THE CLEAN UP BILL
IT'S AS UP --
TO AB THREE SEVENTY FIVE THE
ANALYSIS.
MY OFFICE WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH STAKEHOLDERS OVER THE
SUMMER RECESS IN IN AUGUST TO
CORRECT ANY FURTHER.
TECHNICL FIXES THAT NEED TO BE
MADE RESPECTFULLY ASK BRAD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
SWEETNESS PLEASE.
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES SAW
SUPPORTERS PLEASE COME FORWARD.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
GOOD MORNING SENATOR DIED.
I'M HERE TODAY SNIFF THE KORAN
ON BEHALF OF THREE OF MY CLIENTS
PRIVACY RIGHTS CLEARINGHOUSE
COMMON SENSE MEDIA AND THE
ELECTRONIC FRONTIER FOUNDATION.
COMMON IN A BIT OF A A TWEENER
STATUS AND CERTAINLY.
NOTING THAT WE DO IN FACT NEED A
TECHNICAL CLEAN UP BILL TO TO
MOVE FORWARD AND AND THE POLICY
DEADLINES --
AT APPRECIATE STOP TAKING AND
MESSAGES AND CALLS FOR ME LATE
LAST NIGHT TO TALK FOR SOME OF
OUR CONCERNS WHICH I I WON'T
BELABOR HERE --
TODAY OTHER THAN TO SAY --
YOU KNOW WE WE HAVE HAVE HAD THE
PROCESS WE HAVE IT'S BEEN
FRUSTRATING I THINK FOR A LOT OF
STAKEHOLDERS ON ON BOTH SIDES --
YEAH DE BY YOU KNOW ANY NUMBER
OF THINGS BEING TIME BOUND BY.
STATUTE AND AND AND
CONSTITUTIONAL BOUNDARIES IN
JUST THE NATURE OF THE NEW
INITIATIVE PROCESS AND SO I
WOULD.
ENCOURAGE THE AUTHOR AND AND AND
I I ASSUME ULTIMATELY THE CO
AUTHORS OF THE OF THIS AND
SUBSEQUENT CLEAN UP BILLS --
TO BEST AS WE CAN GRAB BACK HOLD
I HAVE A PROCESS THAT ALLOWS FOR
PUBLIC DELIBERATION THERE'S A
LOT OF POWER IN WORDS AND SO.
AND YOU KNOW BE AND BE AT THAT
THE WORDS AND IN THE LANGUAGE
NOW WERE ACCIDENTAL OR
UNINTENTIONAL OR DID CLEAN UP --
NAY THERE'S A LOT OF HER AT THE
EXISTING PROCESS AND SO I WOULD
JUST URGE CAUTION AND AND TO
EXPAND THE SCOPE OF DELIBERATION
AND AND AGAIN MUCH AS POSSIBLE.
GRAB HOLD OF A NORMAL PROCESS SO
THAT WE CAN THAT SOME OF THE
CONCERNS THAT FOLKS HAVE --
AS AS CHANGES ARE MADE ON A GO
FORWARD THINKING [inaudible]
NEXT PLACE.
THINKING ATTACK OR THE CONSUMER
ATTORNEY THE CALIFORNIA WE THINK
THE AUTHOR FOR ALL THE WORK
YOU'VE DONE TO PROTECT CONSUMERS
FROM DATA BREACHES WE THINK THE
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE COUNSEL FOR
THEIR QUICK WORK. TO TRY AND
WORK ON THESE TECHNICAL ISSUES
WE'D LIKE TO WORK ON TIGHTENING
UP THEN I MISS THE PRIVATE RIGHT
OF ACTION PIECE WE UNDERSTAND
THE INTENT TO LIMIT THE PRIVATE
OF ACTION TO JOSS.
THE DATA BREACH PORTION OF THE
BILL BUT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT ANY EXISTING LEGAL RIGHTS
REMEDIES ARE PROTECTED.
THROUGH LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE AUTHOR COMMITTEE
STAKEHOLDERS ON TIGHTENING UP
THIS LANGUAGE THANK YOU THANK
YOU MATCHA ADDITIONAL.
SUPPORTERS.
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MIKE MATIC
CONSUMER WATCHDOG A IN SUPPORT
AND CONGRATULATE ALL THAT WHO.
AMAZING EFFORT ON THIS THING FOR
EVERYBODY THANK YOU THANK YOU
MATCH.
HOW?
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
MORNING MR CHAIRED MEMBERS THEIR
BOOT ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE TESTIFYING
TODAY.
MORE OF IT TWEENER STATUS IS
WILD ELEMENT OF OUT OF SUPPORT
OMITTED NEUTRALITY IT COLEMAN OF
CONCERN WHICH SOME OF WHICH HAS
BEEN ALLEVIATED BY MISTER DODDS
REMARKS FRANKLY --
VERSUS WANT TO THANK SENATOR
DODD -- FOR
BY REMOVING THAT ADDITIONAL DATA
BREACH LANGUAGE FROM THE BILL
OBVIOUSLY WITH AB THREE SEVENTY
FIVE BUSINESSES ARE GOING TO BE
COMPLYING WITH A LOT MORE --
LAWS AND HAVE A LOT MORE
LIABILITY AND SO I THINK THAT
WAS SOMETHING THAT WAS TAKEN
INTO CONSIDERATION HERE WE'RE
REALLY GRATEFUL FOR THAT --
ALSO ONE I THINK SENATOR DODD
FOR ENSURING THAT THERE IS THIS
SHORTER TERM TECHNICAL FIX
VEHICLE GOING FORWARD --
WITH RESPECT TO THE THREE
ASPECTS OF THE LANGUAGE THAT ARE
INCLUDED IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS --
WE CERTAINLY AGREE IN THE
CONCEPT OF MAKING SURE THAT THE
PR A IS EXPLICITLY LIMITED TO
JUST THE DATA BREACH SECTION --
YOU KNOW THE NEWSPAPER FIXES IT
YOU KNOW IN CONCEPT THAT'S GREAT
IN THAT THESE OTHER TECHNICAL
FIXES.
I MEAN CONCEPTS SHOULD BE GREAT
WE JUST NEED MORE TIME TO REVIEW
THE SPECIFIC LANGUAGE AND MAKE
SURE THAT WE AGREE WITH THE
LANGUAGE --
AND THEN FINALLY --
OBVIOUSLY THERE'S A TIGHT
TIMEFRAME. SEVENTY FIVE AND
MAKING SURE THAT WE HAVE A
VEHICLE TO MOVE FORWARD TODAY
BUT WE JUST WANT TO ENSURE THAT
GOING FOR THE BUSINESS COMMITTEE
WILL HAVE THAT MEANINGFUL
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT.
DISCUSS AND REQUEST ADDITIONAL
FIXES TO BE INCLUDED IN THIS
BILL IT SOUNDS LIKE THAT WILL BE
THE CASE BASED ON WHAT SENATOR
DODD WAS SAYING WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT.
AND CERTAINLY YOU KNOW BEYOND
JUST TRULY TECHNICAL FIXES YOU
KNOW WHAT WE'RE LOOKING FOR ARE
YOU KNOW ADDRESSING OTHER ISSUES
THAT MAY BE LESS CONTROVERSIAL --
ADDRESSING NEGATIVE CONSEQUENCES
THAT MAY STEM FROM THE BILL THAT
WERE UNINTENDED THAT SORT OF
THING THAT'S WHAT WE'RE HOPING
TO ACCOMPLISH WITH --
WITH SB ELEVEN TWENTY ONE AT
THIS POINT WE'RE WORKING ON A
LIST OF OF THOSE THINGS RIGHT
NOW AND I WE BELIEVE EVERYONE
WILL BENEFIT IF WE CAN INCLUDE
AS MANY OF THEM AS POSSIBLE AS
SOON AS POSSIBLE --
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE AT
KEVIN CAN WITH INTERNET
ASSOCIATION I WON'T BELABOR THE
POINT ECHO SENTIMENTS.
OF MY COLLEAGUE FROM CAL CHAMBER
THANK YOU MUCH.
EXPLAINS.
MISTER CHAIR LAURA BUT WITH
TECHNIQUES ONE ASSOCIATE ARE
COMMON TO THOSE OF CAL CHAMBER
ESPECIALLY HEARING THAT THIS
BILL REMAINS OPEN FOR FURTHER
CONSIDERATION.
OF WHAT INDUSTRY WANTS TO AS HE
FIX THIS BILL MOVING FORWARDS TO
THINK YOU [inaudible]
THANKS PLACE.
MISTER CHAIRMAN WAS CHRIS MCKAY
WE ON BEHALF OF THE COMPUTING
TECHNOLOGY INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
AND WE SHARE THE CONCERNS OF
CHAMBER ENUMERATED.
THANK YOU BACKSPACE.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
KEVIN GOULD WITH CALIFORNIA
BANKERS ASSOCIATION.
WE PERCEIVE THE GRAMM LEACH
BLILEY EXEMPTION THAT WAS IN AB
THREE SEVENTY FIVE WE THINK IT
CAN BE IMPROVED.
WE'VE DRAFTED LANGUAGE THAT WE
THINK --
ACCOMPLISHES THAT GOAL OF
IMPROVEMENT.
OUT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE'S STABILITY IN THE
FINANCIAL MARKETS --
ENTITIES THAT ARE COVERED BY GOP
I HAVE A LOT OF PROTECTIONS WITH
REGARD TO THE SHARING OF
INFORMATION --
AND HOW THAT INFORMATION IS HELD --
AND THAT IS ALSO JOINED BY
WHAT'S IN THE THE SENATE BILL
ONE PROVISIONS IN THE FINANCIAL
CODES WE LOOK FORWARD.
TO WORKING WITH THE SENATOR
THROUGH THE SUMMER AND HOPE TO
GET OTHER REFINEMENTS AYE INTO
INTO OF THIS PARTICULAR BILL
THANK YOU I CAN EXPRESS.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE JIM E. WORKED WITH A
CALIFORNIA NEWS PUBLISHERS
ASSOCIATION.
WANT TO THANK THE SENATOR --
FOR HIS PROPOSAL TO TRY TO
ADDRESS THE CONCERNS THAT WE'VE
RAISED AN IDENTIFIED IN AB THREE
SEVENTY FIVE HOW WE'RE NOT THERE
YET -- BUT
WE ARE TO LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOUR STAFF --
AND SENATOR AND HIS STAFF I TO
ADDRESS THOSE CONCERNS OUT WE
ALSO SHARE SOME OF THE CONCERNS
THE CHAMBER ARTICULATED IN AND
LOOK FORWARD --
TO WORKING THROUGH THIS --
WITH SOME TIME I TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE GET THIS ONE RIGHT THANK
YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU MUCH
NEXT PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING SHERRI MICKEY
REPRESENT A CALIFORNIA CREDIT
UNION.
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA AND WE'D
ASSURE THEIR COMMENTS AND ECHO
THE COMMENTS I SHOULD SAY OF THE
CALVARY BANKERS ASSOCIATION'S
PERTAINS THE GRAMM LEACH BLILEY
ACT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT PLACE.
CHAIR MEMBERS JOHN TREATING ON
BEHALF ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
LIFE AND HEALTH INSURANCE
COMPANIES WE'D LIKE --
ECHOED STRANDS EXPRESSED BY THE
CHAMBER AND ALSO BY THE BANKERS.
THANK YOU NEXT PLACE.
CHAIRMAN --
MICHAEL GETTING MEMBERS MICHAEL
GETTING PERSONAL INTEREST
FEDERATION I THINK OF THE
AUTHORS VERY FAMILIAR WITH THE
INSURANCE INDUSTRY BY NOW.
AN ECHO OF THE OTHER COMMENTS
AND ALSO CERTAINLY APPRECIATE
THAT I WE WORK TOGETHER.
TO AMEND THE BILL THANK YOU SIR.
THANK YOU MUCH NEXT PLACE.
JURY MEMBERS KEVIN BACK AMERICAN
CIVIL LIBERTIES UNION OF
CALIFORNIA OR NOT IN OPPOSITION
I THINK WE HAD A POSITION IT
WOULD HAVE TO BE UP --
THERE APPEAR TO BE SUGGESTIONS
FOR CHANGES THAT ARE NOT.
QUITE TECHNICAL THEIR OTHER
TECHNICAL CHANGES THAT DON'T
SEEM TO HAVE BEEN ADDRESSED YET.
ON AND WE'RE I COULD JUST ON
REINFORCED REMARKS OF MISS
CORBIN I THINK THIS IS A TIME TO
GO SLOW AND MAKE SURE THERE
DOESN'T SEEM TO BE A RUSH RIGHT
NOW.
WE'VE GOT A LITTLE BIT OF TIME
LET'S DO THIS RIGHT.
AND AND AND MAKE SURE THAT WE WE
DON'T GO THROUGH THE SAME --
HASTE WITH WHICH WE THE PREVIOUS
BILL WAS ENACTED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT PLACE.
MR MEMBERS JOHN DURING ABOUT THE
CIVIL JUSTICE SOCIAIS XIN WE DO
WE HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT --
THE WE SUPPORT THE IDEA OF
LIMITING THE PRIVATE ACTION THAT --
THESE SECURITY BREACHES WE THINK
THERE'S STILL NEEDS TO BE WORKED
ON THEIR ON AND I WOULD SAY I
WOULD ADVENTURE TO SAY THAT I
THINK THAT THE EVENTUAL CLEAN A
BILL HAS TO GO A LITTLE BIT
BEYOND TECHNICAL.
ON TO FIX SOME OF THE THINGS I
THINK CONSUMERS WILL BE.
ON DISAPPOINTED AND IF WE DON'T
GET THEIR CLINICAL DRUG TRIALS
YOU'RE A RAPID REWARDS ACCOUNTS
THOSE TYPE OF THINGS WE STILL
LOOK FOR TO WORKING WITH SENATOR
ON THE APPRECIATE HIM TAKING UP
THE BANNER OF OF OF WORKING OUT.
THANK YOU NEXT PLACE.
FAILING BORDERS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH
UNDERWRITERS WE ARE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE IN LITTLE MINOR COMMENTS
WITH THOSE OF THE CHAMBER.
THANK YOU NEXT PLACE JERRY
DOESN'T HAVE THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF LICENSED
INVESTIGATORS AND WE ALSO
ALIGNER COMMENTS FOR THOSE OF
THE CHAMBER.
NEXT PLEASE MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS BERNIE OROZCO AT THE
COMPANY CABLE AND
TELECOMMUNICATIONS ASSOCIATION --
WE ARE ALSO ALIGN WITH ORANGE
INDUSTRY FOLKS THE CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE.
I WOULD LIKE AND WE HAVE A
NUMBER OF TECHNICAL ISSUES WE
THINK NEED TO BE ADDRESSED SO WE
APPRECIATE THAT OPPORTUNITIES
YOU THAT OVER THE SUMMER RECESS --
WITH THE AUTHOR ONE POINT I'D
LIKE TO JUST MAKE NOW THOUGH IT
YOU HAD A VERY GOOD DISCUSSION
ABOUT WHAT IS REASONABLE
SECURITY AND I THINK MISPLAYED
WAS TALK ABOUT A SAFE HARBOR
ISSUE SO. FOR THE PARENT OF
ACTION YOU CANNOT HAVE A PART
RIGHT OF ACTION IF THERE'S A
SECURITY --
REASONABLE SECURITY MEASURES AND
IN YOUR HAIR DATA MANAGEMENT --
SO THAT SAME DISCUSSION THAT YOU
HAVE WHAT IS REASONABLE SECURITY
SO I THINK THAT NEEDS TO BE
FLUSHED OUT THAT'S ONE OF THE
THAT THE MAIN THING SO MISTER
CHAO.
WHEN YOUR BILL PASSED AB THREE
SEVEN FIVE WE SENT YOU A LIST OF
ISSUES THAT WE LIKE TO SEE
ADDRESSABLE JUST READ OF REDO
THAT LETTER MAY BE SENT?
TO THE SENATOR HERE TO SENATOR
DODD BUT ONE OF WHAT CONSTITUTES
REASONABLE SECURITY AND THAT'S
GOING TO BE VERY VERY IMPORTANT
BECAUSE IT THAT WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION.
THANK YOU NICE PLACE.
I FEEL THE GRIEF FOR THE
ADVANCED MEDICAL TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION AND ON BEHALF OF
CALVARY LIFE SIGNS ASSOCIATION
JUST ASSOCIATE OR COMMENTS FOR
THOSE OF THE CHAIN.
THANK YOU ARE VERY MUCH NEXT
PLEASE.
MARGARET GLAD SHE NEVER HAVE
CALIFORNIA RETAILERS ASSOCIATION
WE ASSOCIATE OUR MARCH WITH
CHAMBER WE THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
DROPPING THE CURRENT CONTENT OF
SB.
ELEVEN TWENTY ONE THE COURT OF
WORKING WITH HIM ON FIXES ON
THEY HAVE THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY BANKING NETWORK WE
ALIGN OURSELVES WITH THE
COMMENTS OF MISTER GORE THAT
CALIFORNIA BAKER SAY SHE'S.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ARE SEEN NO OTHER OPPOSITION
LENNY'S LET ME TAKE A MINUTE TO
THANK THE AUTHOR. FOUR FOR
THOUGHT ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS
AND VOLUNTEERING HIS SIR S. B.
ELEVEN TWENTY ONE TO BE THE
VEHICLE.
ARMED FOR THE NECESSARY
TECHNICAL CLEAN UP BY TWO AB
THREE SEVENTIES.
FIVE ARE AS WE KNOW DE
ABBREVIATED AMOUNT OF TIME THAT
WE HAD TO GET AB THREE SEVEN
FIVE SIGNED INTO LAW.
A REALLY RESULTED IN THE NUMBER
OF DRAFTING IN TECHNICAL ERRORS.
ALL IN I'M VERY HAPPY THAT THERE
IS NOW AT A VEHICLE ARE
DEDICATED TO ADDRESSING THE
ERROR STAT MOST IMMEDIATELY
REQUIRE CORRECTION.
ALL DURING THIS LEGISLATIVE
SESSION SO WE CAN TURN TO MORE
CLARIFYING AMENDMENTS.
IN ANOTHER CLEAN UP BILL FOR
NEXT YEAR.
NOW WITH THAT BEING SAID THIS
VEHICLE IS ALSO INTENDED TO DRAW
CERTAIN COMMITMENTS THAT WERE
MADE BY MYSELF SENATOR.
IT'S BURKE AS WELL AS SENATOR
DIED DURING THE PASSAGE OF A
THREE SEVENTY FIVE RELATING TO
THREE PARTICULAR ISSUES FIRST A
PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION.
AND A SECOND PROTECTED DUNLUCE
GATHERING ACTIVITIES.
AND A TECHNICAL CLEANUPS
ENVISIONED BY THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE NOT WHO OF
THESE ITEMS ARE CURRENTLY
REFLECTED IN THE AMENDMENTS IN
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS.
OUR FIRST THERE'S LANGUAGE
DESIGNED TO ENSURE THAT THE
PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION UNDER.
THREE SEVENTY FIVE IS LIMITED TO
ONLY THE DATA BREACH PROVISION
OF THE NEW LAW AS WE HEARD FROM
MULTIPLE TARA FOCUSED TODAY.
AS YOU YOU MAY RECALL WE ALSO
DISCUSSED AS LIMITATION AT EVERY
SINGLE HEARING.
ARE DURING THE PASSAGE OF THREE
SEVENTY FIVE LAST WEEK.
AND WE MADE A PUBLIC COMMITMENT
TO ENSURING THAT THE PRIVATE
RIGHT OF ACTION DOES NOT APPLY.
A MORE BROADLY THAN ORIGINALLY
INTENDED.
SO THEREFORE TOGETHER WITH THE
EXISTING LANGUAGE IN THE NEW LAW
ON THE PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION
WILL APPLY ONLY TO THE DATA
BREACH PROVISION.
ARM.
AND ANY OTHER RIGHTS AND
OBLIGATIONS THAT MIGHT EXIST
UNDER OTHER LAWS WILL REMAIN
UNAFFECTED ARE BY THIS
LIMITATION.
NOW THAT BEING SAID THE
AMENDMENT IN THE ANALYSIS IS A
PLACE HOLDER ME UNDERSCORE THAT.
INTENDED TO BEGIN THE
CONVERSATION ABOUT HOW MUCH
ASSURANCES SHOULD BE MADE.
IN STATUE.
AS THE AUTHOR AND COMMITTEE
CONSIDER FEEDBACK ON HOW TO BEST
ACHIEVE THE DESIRED RESULT.
SECONDLY THE CALIFORNIA NEWS
PUBLISHER NEW --
ASSOCIATION EXPRESSED CONCERN
THAT THREE SEVEN FIVE COULD
INFRINGE ON FIRST AMENDMENT
PROTECTED NEWS GATHERING
ACTIVITIES AGAIN AS WE TESTIFIED
DURING THE PASSAGE OF THREE
SEVENTY FIVE LOSES THIS WAS NOT
WHAT WE INTEDED AS WE
SPECIFICALLY INCLUDED LANGUAGE
IN THAT BILL. TO ENSURE THAT THE
LAW DIDN'T AFFECT [inaudible]
JOURNALISM.
SO ACCORDINGLY THE AMENDMENTS
INCLUDE A CARVE OUT FOR THOSE --
FOOD FOR THESE PROTECTED NEW
SCATTERING ACTIVITIES.
SIMILAR TO THE PRIVATE RIGHT OF
ACTION AMENDMENT THIS LANGUAGE
IS INTENDED TO FUNCTION AGAIN AS
A PLACE HOLDER.
WHILE INTERESTED PARTIES PROVIDE
FEEDBACK TO THE AUTHOR IN THE
COMMITTEE ON HOW TO BEST ADDRESS
THIS ISSUE AND AVOID ON INTO THE
CONSEQUENCES [inaudible]
SO FINALLY.
SINCE RELEASING THE MOCK UPS SET
OF AMENDMENTS THERE HAVE BEEN
QUESTIONS REGARDING THE CHANGE.
FROM THEIR WORK TERM EXPRESS
AUTHORIZATION TO AFFIRMATIVE
AUTHORIZATION QUOTE UNQUOTE.
IN SECTION SEVENTEEN NINETY
EIGHT ONE POINT.
ONE TWENTY NOW THE PURPOSE OF
THAT FOR THAT AMENDMENT IS TO
BRING CONSISTENCY TO THE SECTION
ABOUT MINORS OPTING IN. TO THE
SALE OF INFORMATION AND IT IS MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT AFFIRMATIVE
AUTHORIZATION WAS ALWAYS OUR
INTEND. FOR THE OFTEN
REQUIREMENTS HOWEVER GIVEN A
NUMBER OF QUESTIONS THAT
POLITICAL THIS PARTICULAR
AMENDMENT HAS GENERATED DAHLE WE
WILL REFRAIN FROM MAKING GOT
AMENDMENT AT THIS TIME.
SO THAT WE CAN HAVE A OF
DIALOGUE ABOUT IT AND TAKE A
CLOSER LOOK.
ARE THE INTENT AGAIN IS TO HAVE
THIS CLEAN UP BILL THAT'S SOME
THAT'S A TECHNICAL AND ARE.
OF A PLACE HOLDER AS WELL AS NON
CONTROVERSIAL.
SO WITH THAT SAID I LIKE TO
THINK THE AUTHOR AGAIN FOR THESE
AMENDMENTS AND I ASK THAT I BE
ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR.
ARE AS WE CONTINUE TO WORK ON
REFINING THIS IMPORTANT ON YOUR
LAW.
SO WITH THAT --
I'D LIKE TO OPEN IT UP FOR
QUESTIONS COMMITTEE MEMBERS
[inaudible]
MISS BAKER.
OKAY MISS ORINDA HAS I THINK
THAT ALL THE SPEAKERS OF SAID IT
VERY WELL IT DID IT DOESN'T
MATTER WHAT SIDE YOU'RE ON
NOBODY IS COMPLETELY HAPPY
BECAUSE THAT IT WASN'T
NECESSARILY.
POINTS SHORT TIMEFRAME A VERY
COLLABORATIVE EFFORT BUT I I
THINK OF I REALLY WANT TO THINK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHAU SENATOR
DODD AND HURTS BERG.
FOR AG GETTING THIS ISSUE OFF
THE BALLOT BECAUSE THIS IS THE
RIGHT WAY TO DO THINGS THAT THAT
WE MOVE FORWARD WE CORRECT THE
DRAFTING ISSUES IN THE TECHNICAL
ISSUES AND YOU ADDRESS THE
PROMISES THAT HAVE BEEN MADE.
IMPORTANT BECAUSE THIS IS A
POLICY THAT CAN REALLY CHANGE.
HOW WE DO IN CALIFORNIA AND WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE LOOK
AT THOSE UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES
AND ADDRESS THEM GOING FORWARD
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH?
THANK YOU MISS BAKER THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN JUST A TWO
THINGS AND ONE IS.
ILL WHAT'S GOING TO BE TALKED
ABOUT.
WE JUST HEARD OVER THE COURSE OF
THE SUMMER RECESS WILL THIS
BLESSED YOU.
WELL THIS COMMITTEE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY.
NOT THAT I'M LOOKING FOR EXTRA
COMMITTEE HEARINGS I WAS HAPPY
TO HAVE FUN WHEN NECESSARY BUT
TO TO HEAR THE AGAIN BECAUSE A
LOT IS ON THAT LIST OF THINGS TO
FIX BEYOND THE MINOR TECHNICAL.
AND THERE WILL BE LANGUAGE TO
SEE THE IMPACT TO EMPLOYERS AND
EMPLOYEES THEREFORE WILL BE
SIGNIFICANT POTENTIALLY --
I DON'T KNOW IF I SHOULD
DIRECTED TO THE CHAIR OF THE THE
AUTHOR BUT I I WOULD THAT'S ONE
QUESTION I HAVE A RE GONNA BE
ABLE TO HEAR THIS AGAIN.
AFTER SOME OF THESE CHANGES ARE
MADE AND THE SECOND IS ONE OF
THE ITEMS I REMEMBER FROM
INFORMATIONAL HEARING --
THAT I ATTENDED ON THE ORIGINAL
BILL.
UP I HAD SUGGESTED THAT.
THERE IS A DELAYED
IMPLEMENTATION BUT THAT THERE BE
A HEARING.
IN THIS BODY.
BOB FOR THE IMPLEMENTATION.
SO AND I DIDN'T HEAR THAT ON THE
LIST OF ITEMS THAT YOU'RE
CONTINUING TO LOOK AT I
APPRECIATED THE AUTHORS --
COMMITMENT COMMITTEE TO CONSIDER
THAT I HOPE THAT WILL BE ONE OF
THE ITEMS YOU MAY ADD TO YOUR
LIST.
SO THAT BEFORE IT BEFORE
IMPLEMENTATION HAPPENS.
WE ARE ABLE TO SAY IS THIS ARE
NOW THE PATH WE REALLY WANT TO
GO DOWN AND I WOULD NOT CONSIDER
THIS THE HEARING.
TO SAY THAT'S WHAT'S HAPPENED SO
I I'M OFFER THOSE TWO POINTS.
FOR CONSIDERATION AND I HOPE
THAT ONE OR BOTH OF YOU MIGHT
ADDRESS THEM THANKS.
WELL IN THE FIRST.
SINCE I'VE BEEN THE ASSEMBLY AND
I'M ASKING YUBA OUGHT WILL DEFER
TO THE CHAIR ON THAT.
ONE YEAH I'LL DEFINITELY DARBY
CONSIDERING THOSE SAD THOSE --
MA WHATEVER WE CAN DO TO KINDA
HELP FACILITATE THE
IMPLEMENTATION I THINK WITH
ROUGHLY CONSIDER.
SO IF YOU CAN ADD THAT TO THE BY
THE WAY ON THE LIST THAT WAS
REFERRED TO BY ON MY THINK
MISTER OROZCO AYE I HAVE NOT
SEEN THAT LIST YET IF YOU CAN
ADD THAT TO AT LEAST I'LL BE
I'LL.
DEFINITELY BE LOOKING AT IT AND
I'LL BE WORKING WITH MISTER AS
THE ALTERNATIVE WOULD BE SO YEAH
I DO WHAT I WANT TO INCREASE
YOUR VERY GRATEFUL AND I THINK
THAT WOULD BE ONE OF THOSE
THINGS THAT WILL BETTER
IMPLEMENT SO VERY GRATEFUL.
FOR THAT.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
COMMENTS MISCONDUCT AT I TWENTY
ABOUT SENATE OUR CHANCE TO
RESPOND TO SOME ABOUT WHAT'S
BEEN SAID IN THAT MAYBE GOES A
LITTLE BETTER SENSE OF WHAT --
THE TRAJECTORY OF THIS
PARTICULAR BILL IS GOING TO BE
WHAT YOUR GOALS ARE FOR ALL FOR
IT -- WHAT
ALTERNATELY WILL BE THE SCOPE?
ULTIMATELY AS YOU HEARD THE
CHAIR -- IT
YOUNG DURING HIS COMMENTS THIS
IS A TACTICAL CLEAN UP BILL YOU
ALSO HEARD FROM THE COMMENTS --
YOU KNOW THAT THERE ARE THERE
ARE SOME AREAS WHERE --
I PEOPLE LIKE TO GO BEYOND THOSE
AYE I WOULD SAY THAT --
HE OUT.
THE DO CHAIR OUTLINED YOUR VERY
VERY CLEARLY AND SPECIFICALLY
WHAT.
AYE HE THOUGHT THAT THE
PARAMETERS OF THAT SHOULD BE IN
THAT PERHAPS DOWN THE LINE --
THERE COULD THERE COULD THERE
COULD BE SOMETHING ELSE I LOOK
AT THIS STILL AS A TACTICAL
CLEAN UP BILL ALONG THE
PARAMETERS THAT THE CHAIR HAD
SET FORTH.
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS ARE AND
MISCELLANEOUS GO HEAD.
THANK YOU FOR PROVIDING THE
VEHICLE IT'S CLEAR THAT THERE
HAVE TO BE TECHNICAL CLEAR A
CLEAN UP.
AND THIS NEEDED TO HAPPEN --
I I THINK BY GETTING IT OUT BY
TODAY THAN YOU HAVE.
YOU KNOWN FORTUNATELY NOT YOU'RE
GONNA HAVE THE REST OF JULY --
FOR ALL OF YOU TO HAVE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE SENATOR
AND REALLY WORKON THE LANGUAGE
TO FINALIZE THAT AND I THINK I
WOULD AGREE WITH MY COLLEAGUE --
THIS BAKER ABOUT HEARING SO THAT
WE CAN HERE WITH THE FINAL
RESULT IS BUT THANK YOU FOR
PROVIDING THE VEHICLE THAT WE
ABSOLUTELY NEED [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WITHOUT THAT YOU MAY
CLOSE I JUST KNEW I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
WORK WITH YOU AND YOUR CREDIBLE
STAFF I KNOW THAT A LOT OF THIS
IS BEEN ON VERY VERY SHORT TIME
LINE.
APPRECIATE THE WORK THANK YOU
WOULD MAKE YOUR MIGHT ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE.
YES I DO I HAVE A MOTION.
A FEW.
MOVED AND SECONDED DATA MADAM
SECRETARY ROLL CALL PLEASE.
MOTIONS DAY PASSES MANIFEST
SIMPLY FOR CHAO TIE SHOWER I
KILEY.
KILEY NOT VOTING BAKER.
BAKER AYE BERMAN.
CALDERON.
CALDERON AYE GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE MULLIN.
OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE AYE VARIOUS
[inaudible]
YES I THE BILLS OUT SEVEN ZERO
THINK THANK YOU VERY MUCH GERMAN
MEMBERS [inaudible]
SO [inaudible]
SURE.
IT'S VERY SAD AREA SO.
SPENT A LOT MORE [inaudible]
TELL [inaudible]
I DON'T [inaudible]
HOW CAN? THREE DO YOU THINK YOU
HAD ON PLEASE ON THE WE TELL YOU
[inaudible]
BUT JACKSON.
SO THIS WAS PART OF
IF
[inaudible]
BOB
HERTZBERG A WELCOME THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN YOU HAVE A
S. B. EIGHT THIRTY EIGHT YEAH
ANYTIME YOU'RE READY YOU MAY
BEGIN.
LONG TIME NO SEE HAVE SLOWLY
RIGHT.
HE THIS IS A THIRTY EIGHT A TO
ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS.
YES THANK YOU.
JUST VERY BRIEFLY ARE I KNOW YOU
KNOW THIS WAS CHAIRED.
IT'S COMMITTEE CERTAINLY SEEMS A
SO AND SO OBERNOLTE IS AN EXPERT
SO MUCH OF THIS.
LOOK WE WOULD THE WORLD IS
CHANGING AT A AT A BREAKNECK
SPEED.
AND ONE OF THE CHALLENGES THAT
WE FACE AND GOVERNMENT IS WE
JUST DON'T HARMONIZE WITH EACH
THAT CHANGE WE'RE REACTIVE
ORGANIZATION.
BUT IT'S SOMETHING LIKE THE TOP
OF THE FOOT CENTEX TOP FIFTY
COMPANIES ELEVEN OF THOSE.
UNDER FORBES' LIST ARE
BLOCKCHAIN COMPANIES.
THEN WE GENERALLY LOOK AT
BLOCKCHAIN IN WE HEAR THE TERM
AND WE ONLY ASSOCIATE IT WITH
THE IDEA.
OF OF OF BUT A BIT COINS AND
IT'S NOT THAT AT ALL.
ITS AWAY TO REORGANIZE SOME OF
THE CHALLENGES THAT WE FACE WITH
THE INTERNET.
WHAT DOES THE INTERNET IT IN
THIS PROVIDE EXPLOSIVELY
VALUABLE?
AT THAT ASPECTS TO OUR LIVES ALL
ACROSS THE WORLD PEOPLE IN
COUNTRIES THAT COULDN'T GET
ACCESS TO STUFF.
HAVE SWITCHED UNBELIEVABLE AND
CERTAINLY THIS COMMITTEE JUST
OUT WITH THE ISSUE OF PRIVACY
SHORN THE CHALLENGES IMPOSED BY
THE INTERNET.
BUT IN ADDITION TO THE PRIVACY
ISSUE WITH THE UNDERLYING ISSUE
SECURITY.
WHAT THE BLOCKCHAIN DOES IF YOU
HAVE ENOUGH ENERGY IT'LL IT
BASICALLY WILL BE ORGANIZES HOW
THE INTERNET INFORMATION?
ARE IS IS IS BE ACCESS SINCE IN
THE SIMPLEST TERMS IF YOU HAVE A
BLOCK OF INFORMATION EACH BLOCK
OF INFORMATION IS STAMPED IN
TIME.
WITH UNIQUE TIME STAMP EACH JUST
PARTICULARLY STAMP OF THAT
PARTICULAR CODE.
AND THEN EACH TASK IS TO IS
CODED TO THE PIECE OF
INFORMATION BEFORE.
AND AFTER IT.
SO IT'S I WOULDN'T SAY IT'S
IMPOSSIBLE BECAUSE THERE'S YOU
KNOW I THINK SOMEHOW IN THE
FUTURE.
BUT IT CERTAINLY PROVIDES AN
EXTRAORDINARY LEVEL OF SECURITY
THAT WE DON'T OTHERWISE HAVE.
SECOND IS STILL OUT THERE BUT
I'VE BEEN KNOWN TO LIVE ON THE
MOON ONCE IN AWHILE --
I THINK IT'S GOING TO BE A BIG
STEP FORWARD TOWARD [inaudible]
DEMOCRATIZATION ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITY IN THE INTERNET
WHAT'S HAPPENED THE INTERNET
HANDFUL OF PEOPLE BEEN ABLE TO
MAKE SO MUCH MONEY.
BILLIONS AND BILLIONS AND TENS
OF BILLIONS OF DOLLARS WATCH
BECAUSE THEY'RE CONTROLLING THE
ADVERTISING A CONTROLLING IS A
UNITED BALLS.
THE AVERAGE PERSON DOESN'T GET A
PIECE OF THAT.
SO I THINK WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN WITH BLOCKCHAIN THE
NOTION IS CALLED TOKENIZATION
BUT BASICALLY YOU'RE GOING TO BE
ABLE TO GET PAID FOR DISLIKING
IT REWARDS POINTS FOR USING YOUR
CREDIT CARD OR MILEAGE A SUBJECT
THAT.
YOU CAN SEE A SIMILAR SYSTEM IS
STARTING TO HAPPEN AROUND THE
COUNTRY AND THE BLOCKCHAIN WILL
ALLOW THAT TO HAPPEN.
SO WHAT HAVE I DONE WITH THIS
BILL.
TRYING TO INTRODUCE THIS VERY
COMPLEX CONCEPT INTO GOVERNMENT.
I TRIED TO INTRODUCE IT WITH A
LIKE THAT YOU WITH WITH TITLE.
A I MET WITH AMBASSADOR TO
VANUATU AND HE'S DOING ALL THIS
TITLE ON BLOCKCHAIN.
BUT HERE WE'VE GOT INTEREST
ENTRENCHED INTERESTS AND IS NO
WAY BECAUSE WE'RE GONNA KILL OFF
THE TITLE INSURANCE COMPANIES IF
WE DO THAT BECAUSE YOU'RE NOT
GONNA NEED A TITLE INSURANCE
COMPANY PAY FOR INSURANCE.
I TRIED TO DO IT WOULD DRIVERS
LICENSES AND BIRTH CERTIFICATES
BUT I GOT ALL THE BLOWBACK FROM
GOVERNMENT TELLING ME HOW HARD
IT'S GOING TO BE.
SO HOW DO I STICK MY TOE IN THE
WATER ON BLOCKCHAIN TO BEGIN THE
INTERVIEWS IN THE CONVERSATION
IN THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS.
AND SO WHAT I DID IN THIS BILL
WAS ALLOW.
COMPANIES TO ARE ON THEIR
PRIVATE COMPANIES TO ORGANIZE
THEIR THEIR STOCK LEDGERS WITH A
BLOCKCHAIN.
PRETTY SMALL DEAL THE WISE AND
IMPORTANT AND ADD THE HOW DOES
THAT HAVE AN ACTUAL GOVERNMENT
PURPOSE TODAY I GIVE YOU TWO
EXAMPLES ARE CLOSE.
COUPLE OF YEARS AGO WE HAD THE
TREASURER'S OFFICE HAD A
SITUATION WHERE SOMEBODY.
HAD SOME BOND MONEY IN SAN
FRANCISCO I CAN'T RECALL THE
SPECIFICS IS PROBABLY IN MY
NOTES BUT AND WE LOOK AT MY
NOTES VERY OFTEN.
BUT BASICALLY SAYS THAT RIPPED
OFF A SOME DUMB DEAL BY FOR BY
FORMING A PARALLEL ACCOUNT. FOR
THOSE WHO NO WHO WHO BEEN
LAWYERS YOU KNOW WHO'VE BEEN
BUSINESS KNOW THAT WHAT HAPPENS
IF YOU OPEN THE COUNT IT'S
ASSUME YOU'VE GOT.
AT CHAO INCORPORATED COMPANY AS
ALL SOMEBODY AND YOU GOT TWENTY
CHECKS COMING IN A DAY IF
SOMEBODY'S TWENTY ROOM PLOYS
WANTS TO RIP YOU OFF.
THEY SIMPLY TAKE THE ARTICLES OF
INCORPORATION TO THE A A
UNANIMOUS WRITTEN CONSENT OR
RESOLUTION SAYING YOU'RE
AUTHORIZED TO SAY HAVE HERTZBERG
SIGN IN THE ACCOUNT I OPEN UP A
PARALLEL ACCOUNT.
AND THEN I TAKE A STEEL CHECKS
FROM THE A CHAO COMPANY AND I
PUT IT IN THE PARALLEL ACCOUNT.
WELL IF YOU HAD IT AS WE ASK FOR
IN THIS BILL A A A A A A
STATEMENT ARE IF YOU'RE ELECTED
TO DO BLOCKCHAIN YET A STATEMENT
ON THE ARTICLES OF INCORPORATION
WHEN YOU WENT TO THAT BANK.
YOU ASKED THAT BANK.
BOMB TO OPEN ACCOUNT THEY WOULD
SAY WILL YOU SHAREHOLDER WHICH
SHOWS THAT WE'RE LEDGER YOU
COULDN'T TELL ME THAT YOU COULD
TAKE A STOCK CERTIFICATE OF THE
BACK OF THE BOOK AND STEEL.
AND PHONY IT UP AND USE A SEAL
AND MAKE A PHONY CERTIFICATE.
THIS BASICALLY HAS SOME VALUE IN
THAT RESPECT SECONDLY THERE WAS
COMPANY ORANGE COUNTY LIVES IN
IRVINE OR TESTING THE CHEMICAL
SPILL.
IT'S BUT IT'S IN THE NOTES
SOMEWHERE IN THE ANALYSIS OF AND
BASICALLY WHAT THEY WERE DOING
WAS PHONING UP STOCK SHARE
CERTIFICATES AND SELLING PHONE
SHARES.
A SAME KIND OF THING YOU
WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO DO WITH THE
COMPANY'S ROSE --
DE DID THAT SO IT DOES HAVE SOME
NEAR TERM BENEFITS IT WAS IN MY
JUDGMENT THE LEAST INTRUSIVE
MANNER.
IN WHICH WE COULD BEGIN TO
INTRODUCE THIS CONCEPT INTO
GOVERNMENT.
AND WITH THAT I TOOK OVER MY
HANDSOME WITNESS WHO'S GONNA.
BLAIR SOCKS OFF THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OFFICE WHEN AS WE THANK IS
CENTER HERTZBERG --
GOOD MORNING COMMITTEE THANKS
FOR HAVING ME I'M JOSEPH CORRAL
AND I'M THE FOUNDER OF CAGE
CHAIN.
CAGE CHAIN IS A CRYPTOCURRENCY
IN BLOCKCHAIN TECHNOLOGY
RESEARCH FIRM.
AND I'M ALSO HERE REPRESENTING
THE BLOCKCHAIN ADVOCACY
COALITION.
I AM A FORMERLY FULLY REGISTERED
IN A REGISTERED INVESTMENT
ADVISER AND TRADER.
I HAVE EARNED AN ADVANCED DEGREE
IN BUSINESS WHEN I BEGAN
RESEARCHING WATCHING TECHNOLOGY
IN CRYPTO CURRENCIES.
I HAVE AUTHORED A PAPER ON THE
SUBJECTS AS WELL BEFORE STARTING
THE CONSULTANCY CAGE CHAIN.
I HAVE HEARD ABOUT QUESTIONS YOU
ALL HAVE REGARDING SENATE BILL.
EIGHT THREE EIGHT A BLOCKCHAIN
IS A DIGITAL LEDGER TOOL THAT
ENABLES DATA TO BE STORED OR
TRANSFERRED SECURITY USING
SECURELY USING BANK GRADE
SECURITY.
I AM IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AS
IT ALLOWS BUSINESSES TO GROW AND
DEVELOP IN AN INNOVATIVE WAY
USING BLOCKCHAIN TECHNOLOGY AND
ITS SECURITY AND VERIFICATION
FEATURES.
THIS BILL WILL ALSO ALLOW JOBS
TO BE CREATED AND FORM A NEW
SOURCE OF TAX REVENUE FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA --
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE THEY GRAVITY THANK
YOU MUCH.
ADDITIONAL SUPPORTERS UP PLEASE
COME FORWARD.
SEEN AN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NINE LET'S BRING BACK TO
THERE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS
COMMENTS.
STILL DOES BEEN MOVED AND
SECONDED.
NO ADDITIONAL COMMENTS AYE AYE.
I WON I WON I THINK YOU ARE
SENATOR HERTZBERG FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD.
TO I I AGREE WITH YOU THAT --
BLOCKCHAIN --
IS -- HAS A
LOT OF POTENTIAL THOSE THAT WILL
HELP UP PROTECT CONSUMER PRIVACY
AS WELL AS SECURITY.
AND I KNOW I KNOW THAT OTHER
STATES HAVE --
USING BLOCKCHAIN TECHNOLOGY IN
VARIOUS ASPECTS I THINK YOU
MENTIONED A COUPLE OF ALREADY.
OF FOR EXAMPLE A DRIVERS SO
REGISTRATION AND I THINK THE
STATE OF WEST VIRGINIA IS
LOOKING MONNING.
YEAH ACTUALLY VOTING ABSOLUTELY
SO I I THINK IT HAS A GREAT DEAL
OF POTENTIAL.
AND YOU KNOW DO YOU THINK THAT I
WAS THINKING ABOUT WAS WHETHER
OR NOT OF BLOCKCHAIN COULD
POTENTIALLY BE USED TO COMBAT
THE RAND SOMEWHERE I KNOW YOU
WORKED ON THAT AS WELL.
AND ON THE HILL CURRENTLY I
THINK --
WE'RE AT THE MERCY OF THESE --
ALL OF THESE TO THESE --
FIRST HOW PERPETRATORS IN
INNOCENCE WHEN WHEN --
BUSINESSES HIT WITH RANSOM WHERE
THERE'S NO NO REMEDY I MEAN I
THINK.
ALL HE COULD DO IS TO GO BACK TO
THE LAST THE VISION OF THE BACK
UP.
AND GENERALLY SPEAKING THERE YOU
KNOW THE BACK OF HIS GOOD AS THE
LAS BACK UP SO DEPENDING ON WHEN
THE TO THE BACKUP SO.
SO YOU KNOW HOSPITALS ARE BEING
YOU KNOW.
WHAT FALLING VICTIMS TO RANSOM
WEARING ON THAT SO SO THIS IS
POTENTIALLY A A --
SOMETHING THAT WE COULD USE TO
COMBAT RANSOMWARE SOME AND I'M
VERY EXCITED ABOUT --
MISTER CALDERON SPILL ALSO
TWENTY SIX LOOK AT IT STUDY SO
THAT WILL TELL US EXACTLY HOW
THE TECHNOLOGY CAN BE USED.
SO SO I'M VERY EXCITED THAT TO
CEASE IS TO THE YOU KNOW THE TO
PUT CALIFORNIA AHEAD OF THE
CURVE HOUSE ALSO.
DISCOVER.
AND I JUST WANNA SAY THAT YOU
FOR THE BILL AND I'M GLAD
WORKING TOGETHER ON THIS ISSUE
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT ISSUE MEAN
JUST TO TO WILL THAT BE ABLE TO
FRAME THE CONVERSATION IS THAT.
A LOT OF THESE COMPANIES THAT
ARE ALREADY HERE IN CALIFORNIA
THAT ARE DOING BLOCKCHAIN THEY
DON'T HAVE CERTAINTY BECAUSE
THERE'S A LACK OF REGULATION
REGULATION AND THEY'RE TERRIFIED
OF WHAT THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
WILL.
UP OR WILL NOT DO AND SO THEY
WANT US AS A STATE TO REGULATE
THEM TO CREATE SOME DEFINITIONS
THAT ALLOWS THEM THE ABILITY TO
KIND OF DO THEIR WORK THEIR
OTHER STATES --
THAT HAVE DONE SOME DEFINITIONAL
WORK ON ON A BLOCKCHAIN IN AND
THE TECHNOLOGY AND THESE
COMPANIES HAVE GONE THERE AND
OPENED UP.
YOU KNOW DOING THINGS AND
FARMING COUNTRIES INTO FARMING
COMES FARMING ESTATE OF FARMING
COMMUNITIES AND SO THIS IS A
HUGE OPPORTUNITY FOR OUR STATE
THAT IF WE DON'T DO SOMETHING
NOW WE DON'T DO SOMETHING. TO TO
ALLOW THESE COMPANIES TO WORK
WITH SOME TYPE OF ABILITY TO
FEEL -- LESS
STRESSED THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT CAN DO SOME BECAUSE
THERE'S THERE IS STATE
REGULATION THEIR STATE
DEFINITIONS AYE IT'S A HUGE
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THIS IS THE TYPE
OF TECHNOLOGY THAT CAN ALLOW US
ONE DAY.
BOTH FROM OUR CELLPHONES WHICH
IS GOING TO BE SEVERAL INCREASED
TURNED OUT I KNOW THE SECRETARY
STATES ACTUALLY WORKING ON THIS
ISSUE RIGHT NOW --
AND SO IT'S A IT'S A HUGE
OPPORTUNITY THAT BEING A REPORT
ON THE ISSUE.
SO WITH THAT CENTER WHICH LIKE
TO CLOSE.
IT DOESN'T ACCOUNT IS A HUGE
ISSUE IT'S IT AND MISTER
CHAIRMAN IT'S UNBELIEVABLE
ESTONIA IS DOING INCREDIBLE
THINGS.
BUT THAT BEST VIRGINIA'S VOTING
ONLY OCCURRED BECAUSE BRADLEY
TASK WAS THE CAMPAIGN PERSON.
FOR MAYOR BLOOMBERG I ACTUALLY
PAID FOR A LOT OF THE SYSTEM
SELF IN AND IT'S A GREAT
CHALLENGE IT'S HARD FOR US. TO
MODERNIZE IN TO PUSH THE
ENVELOPE WHO JUST EXPERIENCED IN
PRIVACY.
AYE IT WHERE STATUS QUO FOLKS
SAY WELL YOU KNOW ARE ARE ARE
ARE HOLDING UP THE SYSTEM AND I
WAS SURE WITH YOU THAT THIS IS A
FIRST IN THE MANY STEPS THAT WE
HAVE TO TAKE.
IN THE TECHNOLOGY SPACE.
ALL ACROSS THE BOARD TO TO TO BE
LEADERS AND I THINK AS MISTER
CALDERON SUGGESTED THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT'S NOT GOING TO ACT IN
THE NEAR TERM IS TO CHALLENGING.
IN THIS IS A PLACE WHERE WE CAN
BE INCUBATORS AND I WOULD
SUGGEST THAT CALIFORNIA HAS THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO BE A A AN
EXTRAORDINARY DEBATER BECAUSE IF
WE CAN LEAD ON THE STUFF YOU'RE
GONNA SEE STATES ALL ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
TAKING THIS ON AND REALLY
SETTING OF STANDARDS I'M PROUD
TO BE INVOLVED WITH THIS AND I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND LOOK
FORWARD TO WORK WITH THE S.
RIVAL.
THANK YOU SENATOR WITH THAT --
LOOK --
THERE'S BEEN.
MOTION SECONDED AS WELL SO.
MADAM SECRETARY RECALL PLEASE
MOTIONS DAY PASSES MANAGED TO
THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR CHAO I SHOUT
HIGH KILEY.
BAKER.
BAKER AYE BERMAN.
CALDERON.
CALDERON AYE GABRIEL.
IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE AYE RAYOS.
GIVE US ALL SIX ZERO WILLIE THE
ROLE THANK YOU SENATOR THINGS.
TO THAT BRINGS US TO THE LAST
BILL.
TODAY AND THAT SIR S. B. ELEVEN
NINETY FOUR SENATOR LARA WELCOME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ELECT TO START BY
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS
PREFERRED ON PAGE FIVE OF THE
KAMALA SYSTEM SURE THAT.
BUSINESSES AND PEACE OFFICERS
ARE AWARE THAT SUCH.
DISCLOSURE OF INFORMATION IS
OPTIONAL IF NO WARRANT
SUBPOENAED OR COURT ORDER IS
PROVIDED ORDER IF KNOW --
INSURGENT CIRCUMSTANCE ARE
PRESENT SOUGHT THANK YOU FOR
YOUR WORK ON THAT --
MEMBERS SB ELEVEN NINETY SEVEN
SIMPLY ASSURES THAT GAS AND
PASSENGER RECORDS OF CALIFORNIA
PATRONS OF LODGING
ESTABLISHMENTS AND PRIVATE BUS
COMPANIES ARE NOT DISCLOSED TO
THIRD PARTIES OR OTHER.
OTHER THAN A CALIFORNIA PEACE
OFFICER LEAVING A COURT ORDER
SUBPOENA OR WARRANT THE BILL
LANDS OF CALIFORNIA'S
LONGSTANDING PRIVACY PROTECTIONS
AND RESPONSE TO RECENT INCIDENTS
IN NEARBY STATES THAT HIGHLIGHT
THE NEED. FOR THESE TARGETED
ADDITIONAL PRIVACY PROTECTIONS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH EFFORTS WHEN
HIS PLEASE.
I INGRAM LEGISLATIVE ATTORNEY
WITH THE ACLU OF CALIFORNIA
WE'RE PLEASED TO CO SPONSOR THIS
BILL.
WE THINK IT ADDS TARGETED
ADDITIONAL PRIVACY PROTECTIONS
THAT ALIGN WITH CALIFORNIANS IS
CHRISTINE LA.
SIMILAR PROTECTIONS OF RD BEEN
AFFORDED ANOTHER AREAS WE
CREATED THE READER PRIVACY ACT
THAT CREATES PRIVACY PROTECTIONS
AROUND PEOPLE'S READING LESS.
AND IT JUST KIND OF GO INTO A
LITTLE MORE DETAIL ABOUT THE
INCIDENTS THAT SENATOR LARA
ALLUDES TO IN WASHINGTON STATE
MOTEL SIX REACH THE PRIVACY OF
OVER TEN THOUSAND OF THEIR
GUESTS NAMES.
AND THEY TURNED THEM OVER TO AYE
AYES THE NAMES BIRTHDATES
DRIVER'S LICENSE NUMBERS LICENSE
PLATE NUMBERS AND ROOM NUMBERS.
AND ARIZONA THEY WERE GENERATING
LESS OF EVERYONE THAT WAS
STAYING IN THE HOTEL EACH NIGHT
AND SENDING IT OVER TO ICE EVERY
MORNING.
AND THIS RESULTED IN PEOPLE
BEING PICKED UP FROM THEIR ROOMS
COUPLES SEPARATED ONE DEPORTED
IMMEDIATELY THE OTHER STYLE AND
ATTENTION.
AND THIS WAS ALL DONE DESPITE
MIDDLESEX HAVING A CORPORATE
POLICY SAYING THAT.
THE INFORMATION I GATHERED
DURING THEIR VISITS --
WAS TO BE CAP IT AND WE THINK
THAT THAT IS WHY THESE
COMMONSENSE PROTECTION SHOULD --
THE GIVEN TO CALIFORNIA
CONSUMERS SO WHEN THEY TRAVEL
THROUGH OUR STATE OR A SPEND A
NIGHT AND ONE OF OUR HOTELS THE
INFORMATION IS SAFE AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK HERE AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MUCH A NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE GINA D'SILVA GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER WE'RE PLEASED TO SUPPORT
SB.
ELEVEN NINETY FOUR A WE MUST
CONTINUE TO ENSURE THAT WE PUT
IN PLACE PROTECTIONS AGAINST
THESE EFFORTS TO TEAR APART
FAMILIES AND DEPORT CALIFORNIANS
HAVE HELPED SHAPE OUR STATE.
AND CONTRIBUTE TO THE SUCCESS OF
OUR ECONOMY AYE WE SEE A GROWING
NUMBER OF HEADLINES BUT WE ALSO
HEAR A NUMBER OF COMMUNITY
STORIES FROM CALIFORNIANS THAT
SHARE YOU KNOW INCIDENTS OF
RACIAL PROFILING.
AND EXTREME FEAR FOR THEMSELVES
IN THEIR LOVES LOANS
[inaudible]
STATE ATTRACT OF LYING TO THE
PUBLIC OF LYING TO ELECTED
OFFICIALS AND WE FEEL THAT THESE
ARE IMPORTANT AND APPROPRIATE
PRIVACY PROTECTIONS TO REALLY
ENSURE THAT CALIFORNIANS CAN
CONTINUE TO PARTICIPATE AND
ENJOY EVERYDAY LIFE --
THESE ARE CONSISTENT WITH OUR
VALUES OUR EFFORTS TO PROTECT
ALL CALIFORNIANS AND OUR
RESISTANCE AGAINST THE
IMPRISONMENT AND DEPORTATION OF
CALIFORNIANS A CALLER STAY HOME
WE THINK SENATOR LOTT AFRICAN
TEAM CHAMPION HE SUFFERED SO
WHERE DO SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ADDITIONAL
SUPPORTERS.
IN GERMANY NOT ASIAN AMERICANS
ADVANCING JUST CALIFORNIA CHUNKS.
THANK YOU NEXT PLACE.
YOU ON PARTNERS SO WE HAVE CHU
LAI AND HERE'S TRUMPS PUTS THEY
CAN MATCH NEXT PLACE.
I HAVE ANOTHER NUMBER PERSON THE
NEXT AND CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT AQ
AT THE OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE LET'S BRING BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COME
MISS BAKER CA.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND US
SENATOR I SUPPORTED A BEFORE
FIFTY AND SOME OF THE OTHER
EFFORTS TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE
IS DUE PROCESS WHEN --
FEDERAL LAW ENFORCEMENT COME TO
THE HOME. TO SCHOOL CAMPUSES TO
WORKPLACE SETTINGS --
STORY I CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THE
EMPHASIS YOUR BILL HAS ON JUST
TRYING TO ENSURE THAT THERE IS
DUE PROCESS WAS THAT'S HOW I
READ IT.
BUT I DO HAVE A CONCERN --
THAT AYE WONDER IF YOU COULD
ADDRESS PLEASE ON THOSE THIRD
PARTIES NOT BEING ICE BUT BEING
THE FEDERAL MARSHAL.
BEING US ATTORNEYS BEING FEDERAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT TASK FORCE THAT --
ARE WORKING TO CONNECT WITH
THOSE WHO ARE HUMAN TRAFFICKERS --
AND PARTICULAR BECAUSE WE TALK
ABOUT LODGINGS AND BUSES.
AND HUMAN TRAFFICKING AS YOU
PROBABLY KNOW IS THE FASTEST
GROWING CRIMINAL ENTERPRISE THE
UNITED STATES THE U. S. THAT
CALIFORNIA HAS THREE OF THE
FBI'S TOP TEN HUMAN TRAFFICKING
LOCATIONS --
TRAFFICKERS UTILIZE HOTELS THEY
UTILIZE BEST SYSTEMS AND I DON'T
WANT TO US TO DO ANYTHING
PERSONALLY THAT IS GOING TO
CREATE BARRIERS BETWEEN.
OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL AND YOU MAY WANT
THEM TO BE OTHER THAN ICE. TO BE
ABLE TO BE PART OF TASK FORCES.
OR INDEPENDENTLY BE ABLE TO
FIGHT CRIME THAT IS HAPPENING --
AND AND THIS BASICALLY IS
POSSIBLY THE BILL IS POTENTIALLY
OVERBROAD IF THE GOAL IS TO
PROHIBIT RAIDS AT HOTELS AND
BUSES AND AND I AGAIN.
I HAVE SUPPORTED OUR EFFORTS
THAT THE LEGISLATURE HAS DONE.
TO PROVIDE JUST THE ROUNDING UP
OF OTHERWISE INNOCENT PEOPLE WE
SHOULD BE FOCUSING ON THOSE
YOU'RE COMMITTING CRIMES.
A THEY CAN YOU ADDRESS THAT
PLEASE BECAUSE THE WAY I READ
THE BILL IS IT DOES PROHIBIT THE
ABILITY OF OTHER FEDERAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT OTHER THAN NICE. TO
BE ABLE TO CONDUCT THOSE EFFORTS
AND LAST THEY GO THROUGH A
CALIFORNIA PEACE OFFICER WHICH
THEN BURDENS ARE CALIFORNIA LAW
ENFORCEMENT SYSTEM.
AND ALMOST FORCES THEM TO HAVE
TO BE THE ONES TO DO IT CAN YOU
ADDRESS THAT PLEASE SURE WE CAN
HAVE.
ARE ASSUME.
FOR SO THE DATA THAT'S BEING
PROTECTED HERE IS THE ACTUAL
LIKE GAS RESTS --
GAS RECORD OR THE PASSENGER
RECORD.
AND NOT YOU KNOW THE ACTUAL LIKE
PERSONS SO IT WOULDN'T STOP
ANYONE FROM --
EFFECTUATE AN ARREST WARRANT FOR
AN INDIVIDUAL AND A FEDERAL.
OFFICER THAT YOU DESCRIBE CAN
STILL GET THAT GAS RECORD A
PASSENGER INFORMATION WITH A
COURT ORDER OR A WARRANT AND
THEN THE FINAL SECTION OF THE
BELL HAS AN EXIGENT
CIRCUMSTANCES --
WHEN THERE'S A THREAT TO THE
BODILY CAUSE THEM?
TO INFORMATION WITHOUT GETTING A
COURT ORDER OR WARRANT.
THANK YOU AND AND PRECIOUS
SENATOR I APPRECIATE THAT.
MY AGAIN REDIFF AND TELL ME IF
I'M CORRECT IS THAT WE'RE TRYING
TO AVOID.
BASICALLY --
IMMIGRATION RAIDS AT HOTELS AND
BUSES AND WE WANT RIGHT BECAUSE
I I HEARD THE TESTIMONY WAS FROM
A SUPPORTED WITNESSES.
THAT THIS IS VERY MUCH WE WE
WANT TO PROTECT THESE AGENCIES
HAVE LIED I THINK IT WAS SAID IN
THAT THEY'RE GOING AFTER PEOPLE
WERE TRYING TO RESIST.
AND WE WHY THEN PUT UP ANY
BARRIERS THAT'S THE GOAL.
WHY PUT UP ANY BARRIERS BETWEEN
NON ICE LAW ENFORCEMENT AND EVEN
KEEP THEM FROM BEING ABLE TO
WIPE Y. PUT?
HOOPS THAT THEY HAVE TO NOW JUMP
THROUGH IN ORDER TO FIGHT CRIME --
THAT IS OUTSIDE OF AN
IMMIGRATION POLICY.
WHY PUT THOSE SHIPS BEFORE THEM
WHY IS THAT NECESSARY IF THE
GOAL IS TO BE PROTECTING PEOPLE
FROM ICE RATES WHICH AGAIN I AM
VERY SYMPATHETIC?
TO RIGHT WHAT WATER PROTECTED
DATA AS AS OUR WITNESSES WAS
SANE AND WE WHAT WE'RE SEEING IS --
IS CERTAIN STATES LITERALLY IF
YOU HAD A SPANISH LAST NAME YOUR
NAME AUTOMATICALLY GOT ON THE
LIST AND THEY GOT CENTER ICE.
I WOULD AND AND THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE TRYING.
TO TELL PREVENT I MEAN WE DON'T
WANNA OBVIOUSLY WANT TO DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO HELP IN THE
EFFORTS OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
BUT WE FEEL THAT IT'S THE DATA
THAT WE'RE TRYING TO PROTECT
HERE AND THAT'S THE GOAL OF THE
BILL.
WE WOULD HAVE YOU CONSIDERED
JUST LIMITING ITS REACH TO ICE.
INSTEAD OF ALL THIRD PARTY MINT
BECAUSE THAT IS VERY BROAD.
I'M AGAIN I'M NOT TRYING TO MEND
YOUR BILL ON THE FLY IN
COMMITTING THAT --
WE YOU KNOW HAVE HAD IS THERE
REASON WHY YOU HAVE NOT MADE IT
THAT [inaudible]
NARROWING SURGICAL.
MEANWHILE THE BILL IS ALSO FOCUS
HAS A LOT OF FOCUS ON ICE IT IS
ALSO JUST --
GOOD PRIVACY PROTECTION TO LIMIT
DISCLOSURE OF THIS VERY
SENSITIVE INFORMATION YOU TURN
OVER.
ALLOTTED DATA TO BOOK A HOTEL
ROOM OR REVOKE --
A BUS TICKET AND SO WE THOUGHT
YOU KNOW THIS STRUCTURE GIVES
GOOD PRIVACY PROTECTIONS AND ALL
SENSE FOR ALL CONSUMERS --
OF THEIR DATA AND THOUGHT IT
STRUCK A REASONABLE BALANCE ON
WHO THE LAWS DISCLOSURES TO IN
THE CONTEXT THAT IT ALLOWS.
DISCLOSURES TO WITH A COURT
ORDER A WARRANT IF SOMEONE IS
TARGETING A GROUP OF INDIVIDUALS
AND HUMAN TRAFFICKING
INVESTIGATION.
IT SEEMS THAT THERE WOULD BE THE
ABILITY TO GET WARRANTS FOR THIS
INFORMATION CAME HERE IT SEEMS
IT WOULD BE THE ABILITY TO GET
WARRANTS YOU MAY BE CORRECT
THAT'S VERY THEORETICAL AND I'M
THINKING OF WHO ARE THE VICTIMS
OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING HOW
PREVALENT IT IS HOW EASY IT.
IS.
TO SKIRT LAW ENFORCEMENT IN SO
MANY WAYS HOW DIFFICULT THE
CRIMES ARE TO PROSECUTE AND IF
THE GOAL IS DATA PROTECTION IT'S
JUST GOOD POLICY TO HAVE A BE ON
ICE WE HAVE SOME OF WE'VE
ACTUALLY BEEN PASSING THEM TODAY.
AND IN THIS COMMITTEE AND THE
STATE HAS VERY RIGOROUS PRIVACY
PROTECTIONS NOW.
FOR YOU KNOW BEST PRACTICES.
ATTACKED CONSUMER DATA I JUST --
I'M GONNA LAY OFF TODAY IN GREAT
HOPE THAT YOU WILL CONSIDER
NARROWING THIS MUCH MORE
SURGICALLY --
WE ABSOLUTELY SHOULD NOT PUT UP
OOPS BETWEEN.
A LAW ENFORCEMENT.
TO GO AFTER HUMAN TRAFFICKING TO
GO ACTIVE GO AFTER VICTIMS OF
CRIME AND THEY USED THESE
LEDGERS THEY USE THIS
INFORMATION TO TRACK DOWN RINGS
I'VE HAD THREE HUMAN TRAFFICKING
RINGS BROKEN UP IN MY DISTRICT
JUST IN THE LAST THREE YEARS.
AND SO I I REALLY STRONGLY
ENCOURAGE THAT --
BECAUSE I DO THINK IT'S OVER
BROAD AND I THINK THAT WHAT
ORIGINAL GOAL OF HAVE PROTECTING
PEOPLE IN THEIR WORKPLACE.
I'M WITH YOU.
OF SO I'M I REALLY HOPE YOU CAN
DO THAT THANK YOU.
AS OUR IN DEPTH --
THAT WAS THE INTERESTING
DISCUSSION AYE AYE ME I'M.
SORT OF SURPRISED THAT THESE --
IF WE'RE JUST WANNA PRIVACY THAT
THESE LETTERS ARE NOT ALREADY
PROTECTED THAT THAT THEY ARE
AVAILABLE TO ANYBODY THAT ASKS
FOR THEM AND AND IS SPECIFICALLY
ON YOUR CONCERNS.
I THINK.
BUT I GUESS I CAN ASK THAT THE
QUESTION.
HOW IF YOU HAVE A HUMAN
TRAFFICKING?
GENERALLY IS IN A LOCAL.
CALIFORNIA LAW ENFORCEMENT
THAT'S GOING AFTER IT NOT
NECESSARILY THE FEDS AND IF IT'S
THE FEDS WOULDN'T THEY BE
PARTNERING WITH LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT HAVE.
HOWEVER WE USUALLY DEALING WITH
SITUATIONS LIKE [inaudible]
THAT.
I'M SORRY THAT IS NOT MY AREA OF
EXPERTISE Y. BE HAPPY TO LOOK
INTO THAT FOUND WITH PEOPLE WHO
WORK IN THAT FIELD I IMAGINE IT
IS.
LOCALS THAT ARE OFTEN DOING THE
ENFORCEMENT OF THAT BUT SO.
THE LOCALS IF THEY THINK THERE'S
A CRIME CAN STILL GET THE LEDGER
AND THERE IS NO RESTRICTIONS AT
ALL.
AND FOR THE FEDS IF IT HAPPENS
THERE INVOLVED WITHOUT THE
LOCALS AND THEY CAN JUST GET A
SUBPOENA CROWD COURT ORDER
AWARENESS.
AND BUT THIS IS WHAT THE
SITUATION IS RIGHT NOW THAT
LEDGER IS AVAILABLE.
TO ALMOST ANY AGENCY WHICH TO ME
SEEMS A PRIVATE LIKE A PRIVACY
ISSUE SO I I I I UNDERSTAND THAT
THIS BILL IS TO PROTECT I MEAN
THAT THAT INFORMATION WAS TURNED
BEING TURNED OVER TO ICE I THINK
IS.
TERRIBLE BUT WE ALSO HAVE TO
LOOK AT THE PRIVACY PART THOSE
LEDGER SHOULDN'T BE AVAILABLE TO
JUST ANY AGENCY IT SHOULD BE.
PEOPLE THAT ARE GOING AFTER
CRIMINALS [inaudible]
SO YOU.
WE AGREE.
BUT I BET IT WOULD BE OF IT
WOULD BE GOOD TO HAVE THE
STATISTICS ON IF YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT HUMAN TRAFFICKING PLEASE.
CERTAINLY DON'T GET FROM HERE TO
THAT INFORMATION AND WE'LL DO
SOME MORE RESEARCH ON FOLLOW UP
WITH SUMMER BAKER ON ON ON OUR
HOME BRITISH ISSUE BROUGHT UP
TODAY.
IF I MAY MISTER CHAIR JUST I'M
SORRY.
IF IT IF IT COULD AND COULD I
MEAN I THINK IT'S AN IMPORTANT
QUESTION AS YOUR AS YOU'RE
LOOKING AT THIS IS THE WHAT
OTHER LAW ENFORCEMENT WHAT FOR
WHAT PURPOSE TO OTHER FEDERAL
AGENCIES.
IF WE WANT TO GET THIS RIGHT
THAT SEEMS LIKE HOMEWORK.
THE SPONSORSHIP BICU AND THAT
THAT SO THAT WE REALLY KNOW WHAT
WE MIGHT BE IMPAIRING.
BUT IT COULD BE.
A VARIETY OF LAW ENFORCEMENT IS
COMPLETELY UNRELATED TO HUMAN
TRAFFICKING AND IMMIGRATION
ENFORCEMENT IT COULD BE A
VARIETY OF FRAUD CRIMES THAT
THERE'S JUST A LOT AND SO I I
WOULD ENCOURAGE TO REALLY --
LOOK AT AND GET A GOOD
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT FEDERAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT OTHERWISE USES
IT FOR AND AGAINST IF YOU GET
SURGICAL THANKS FOR INDULGING ME
ON THAT SECOND POINT.
MR OBERNOLTE THANK YOU MISTER
OTHER DIFFERENT CONCERN WITH THE
BILL THE ENFORCEMENT IN THIS
BILL CREATES A PRIVATE RIGHT OF
ACTION WHERE.
SOMEONE WHO IS SUBJECTED TO A
NON AUTHORIZED BREACH OF THEIR
INFORMATION.
THEN CAN BRING A CIVIL ACTION
AGAINST THE AGENCY THAT --
THE EFFECTUALLY THAT THAT BREACH
[inaudible]
NOW OTHER.
CONSUMER PROTECTION BILLS THAT
WE HAVE PASSED RECENTLY FACT
WHEN WE PASSED EARLIER THAT IN
THIS HEARING TODAY.
I HAVE A YOU KNOW I SIMILAR
SUBJECT MATTER BUT THEY ENTRUST
ENFORCEMENT TO ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S CITY ATTORNEYS AND
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS.
AND I THINK IN CASES LIKE THIS
THAT'S A MORE APPROPRIATE VENUE
BECAUSE A DATA BREACH.
BY AN AGENCY IS LIKELY TO BE NOT
JUST ONE OR TWO PEOPLE BUT A
WHOLE CLASS OF PEOPLE AND IT
SEEMED LIKE.
AVOIDING THOSE KIND OF SYSTEMIC
ABUSES WOULD BE BETTER HANDLED
BY SOMEONE LIKE ATTORNEY GENERAL
CAN YOU.
CAN YOU TELL US WHY YOU DIDN'T
GO THAT ROUTE INSTEAD CREATED A
PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION IN THIS
BILL.
WE THINK THAT BOTH REMEDIES ARE
APPROPRIATE HERE THIS.
TYPE A DISCLOSURE ONE AND BE A
DATA BREACH --
SITUATION IT'S WHEN THE ACTUAL
HOTEL A BUS COMPANY VOLUNTARILY
TURNS THIS INFORMATION OVER SO.
THEY HAVE CONTROL OVER THEIR
ACTIONS IN THIS LAW PUTS THEM ON
CLEAR NOTICE THAT SUCH
DISCLOSURE IS NOT PERMITTED AND
SO WE THINK IF THEY WERE. TO
TAKE THAT AFFIRMATIVE STEP
DESPITE THAT THAN HAVING THE
OPTION OF A PRIVATE RIGHT OF
ACTION FOR INDIVIDUALS.
WHO ARE HARMED BY THIS IS
APPROPRIATE WHILE STILL ALLOWING?
FOR ALL THE OTHER ENFORCEMENT
MECHANISMS BY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S CITIZENS TOURNEY'S
AND THE ATTORNEY GENERAL.
DOES THE BILL ACTUALLY ALLOW
THAT BECAUSE I DON'T READ THAT
IN THE BILL.
I BELIEVE IT DOES ADAM MCCANN
LOOK INTO THAT MAKE SURE.
AND I DON'T THINK THERE'S ANY
PROHIBITION.
ON AS IN ANY LAWS THAT ARE ON
THERE AT WHAT READ ANYTHING
ABOUT THAT BUT ULTIMATELY MY
CONCERN AND IT'S SOMETHING THAT
WE'VE SEEN IN OTHER AREAS.
IN CONSUMER PROTECTION LAW WHICH
IS THAT YOU HAVE I MEAN WHAT WE
WERE ON THE SAME TEAM WHERE WE
WANT TO ENFORCE.
STRONG CONSUMER PROTECTIONS BUT
WE KNOW THAT WE HAVE PREDATORY
LAW FIRMS OUT THERE THAT ARE
LOOKING FOR EXCUSES TO INSTITUTE
CLASS ACTION LAWSUITS AND HAVE A
PROFIT MOTIVE THEIR MOTIVE IS
NOT ENFORCEMENT OF THE LAW THERE
FORCED.
THEIR MOTIVE IS TO MAKE MONEY.
AND THEY TRY AND PICK UP LITTLE
GOTCHA CASES WHERE THERE BEN ON
AUTHOR OF PERHAPS UNWITTING
VIOLATIONS OF CONSUMER
PROTECTION LAW AND AND YOU KNOW
THEY THEY USE THAT TO EXPLOIT.
THE COMPANIES THAT WERE INVOLVED
AND A THAT THAT'S NOT AN
APPROPRIATE WAY TO ENFORCE.
CONSUMER PROTECTION LINE SO I I
HAVE TO RESPECTFULLY OPPOSETHE
BILL.
TODAY BECAUSE OF THAT AND ONE
ENCOURAGE YOU IF THERE'S A BILL
MOVES FORWARD HERE TO CONSIDER.
CHANGING THE ENFORCEMENT TO BE.
GOVERNMENTAL ATTORNEYS GENERAL
DISTRICT ATTORNEY CITY ATTORNEYS
BECAUSE I THINK THAT'S A MUCH
MORE APPROPRIATE VENUE TO BRING
ACTION IN CASES LIKE THIS.
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR WHEN I'D
QUESTIONS.
SEEING NONE ARE LET LET ME THANK --
THE SENATOR FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD I THINK OVERALL
IT'S A IT'S A GOOD MEASURES VERY
GOOD MEASURE AS ONE OF ADDRESSES.
SOME OF THE ISSUES RAISED AND
LET ME ENEMY SAY THAT UNDER THE
FOURTH AMENDMENT ANY LAW
ENFORCEMENT EITHER FEDERAL OR
OTHERWISE.
ON WHEN THE DEMAND FOR THESE
RECORDS WOULD THAT WOULD REQUIRE
A WARRANT --
I THINK THE BILL ONLY LIMITS
THOUGH THE VOLUNTARY DISCLOSURE --
OF THESE RECORDS TO THIRD
PARTIES IF I'M NOT MISTAKEN
INCLUDING OUR FEDERAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT IS IS THAT NOT
CORRECT.
THAT IS CORRECT SO SO I THINK I
THINK ARE YOU KNOW HOW
UNCOMFORTABLE IT SUPPORTING THE
BILL -- AS
HIS BUT I DO WANT TO ASK THE
SENATOR --
TO FOLLOW UP ON SOME OF THE
SUGGESTIONS THAT BEEN RAISED
TODAY ARE AND IF SO TO THE
EXTENT YOU CAN YOU CAN PROVIDE
US WITH INFORMATION THAT'S BEEN
REQUESTED AS WELL THAT THAT
WOULD BE GOOD ABSOLUTELY WILL
COME FROM THE WORK ON THE ISSUES
THAT.
SUMMER BAKER BROUGHT UP THOSE
IMPACTS ONLY WANT TO MAKE SURE
WE'RE NOT FOUND.
YEAH TO SPARSELY AFFECTING ANY
TYPE OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING CASES
AGAIN AND REGARDS TO MY GOOD
FRIEND MISTER OBERNOLTE.
THIS IS A COMPANY THAT'S
WILLINGLY GIVING OUT INFORMATION --
I THINK IT'S APPROPRIATE FOR US
TO BE WOODROW FOLKS THAT ARE
SEEKING REMEDIES PEOPLE HAVE
ACCESS TO THOSE.
AYE AS OPPOSED TO A DATA BREACH
WHICH IS VERY DIFFERENT.
SO I'M AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR A VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
LIKE TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION.
THE BILL IS AND HAS BEEN MOVED
AND SECONDED THAT THE
RECOMMENDATION IS TO PASSED AS
AMENDED. TO <c.green> FOR TO THE</c>
ASSEMBLY FLOOR I SAY WITHOUT THE
MADAM SECRETARY UP PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
MOTIONS DEEP PASSES AMENDED TO
THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR CHAO HIGH
CHAO AYE KILEY.
BAKER [inaudible]
BERMAN.
CALDERON.
CALDERON AYE GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE NOW REYES.
REYES AYE.
X. THAT GIVES CHAIRMAN THANK YOU
VERY MUCH --
STILL WILL AND SCOTT SHOW WE GO
DOWN.
BEFORE WE DO THE ROLL CALL LET
ME TAKE A MINUTE TO THANK ALL MY
COLLEAGUES --
FOR BEING APPLIED AT THIS
COMMITTEE THIS UP PAST CYCLE
IT'S BEEN GREAT WORKING WITH ALL
OF YOU.
AND I INCLUDING OUR NEWEST
MEMBER AT WELCOME --
FROM IS GABRIEL AND ALSO I WANT
TO THINK OF HOW STAFF OF FOR
THEIR DILIGENT WORK.
AND IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING THAT --
THROUGHOUT OUR REPUBLICANS
CONSULTANT IS STILL WITH US FOR
THE LAST DAY TODAY AND HE'S
GONNA BE JOINING A MEMBER'S
OFFICE SO --
IT WAS A IT'S BEEN GREAT WORKING
WITH HIM --
TO TO A LARGE EXTENT AND I'LL
TOTALLY ENJOY WORKING WITH HIS
CELL.
ARE THE BEST OF LUCK TO YOU AND
OUT WITH A FOUR TO COULDN'T YEAH
YEAR -- AND
FACT NEXT YEAR WE DON'T KNOW
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN AS RIGHT
TO MAKE IT IS A OF THE COMMITTEE
IS CONCERNED SO.
HOPEFULLY YOU GUYS WILL BE BACK
AND HOPEFULLY I'LL BE HERE TO
SAY.
SO IT'S BEEN IT'S BEEN WONDERFUL
EXPERIENCE WORKING WITH ALL OF
YOU YES MS BAKER GO AHEAD
ADMIXTURE JUST TO IF YOU CAN
INDULGE AGAIN THAT WE REALLY
THINK OUR CONSULTANT FOR ITS
GOOD WORK ICE BEEN ATROPHY I
THINK ALL THE MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE MAY INCLUDE OUR CAUCUS
ESPECIALLY SO.
MANY OF US HAVE COMMITTEES AND
OTHER PLACES HERE AND JUST --
VERY GRATEFUL AND I KNOW WE ALL
WISH HIM WELL CERTAINLY ARE.
COLLEAGUES DO IN HIS NEXT
ADVENTURE.
THINK ABOUT THINK ABOUT.
SO WITH THAT LET'S THAT CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ON BECAUSE OF
THESE BILLS THAT.
SHE WE JUST GO DOWN THE LIST
MANY ME [inaudible]
AND LET'S [inaudible]
HAVE.
IT'S GOING TO BE.
HELL I SP. THREE TWENTY SEVEN
JACKSON PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS [inaudible]
BERMAN [inaudible]
BERMAN I BELT GOT BILL IS OUT
THERE.
NEXT WE HAVE.
S. B. A THIRTY EIGHT THAT'S
HERTZBERG GOTH PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS [inaudible]
KILEY.
BERMAN A BERMAN AYE.
GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I ANDREAS.
RADIUS I THAT BILL IS OUT ALSO
[inaudible]
YEAH.
NEXT BILL S. --
S. B. ELEVEN TWENTY ONE AND
STUCK STOCK PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS [inaudible]
BERMAN [inaudible]
BERMAN I THAT BILL IS OUT.
AND FINALLY WE HOUSE A LARA S.
B. ELEVEN NINETY FOUR PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS KILEY
[inaudible]
BAKER.
BERMAN I'VE BERMAN AYE.
WE WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
A MR KILEY ON A COUPLE OF BILLS
.
I THINK.
YOU'LL HAVE TO THOSE. EIGHT
THIRTY EIGHT HERTZBERG.
I I I KILEY AYE KILEY AYE AND
THE LAST.
LARA BELT --
SB ELEVEN NINETY FOUR ARE
[inaudible]
KILEY [inaudible]
KELLY NOW.
I VERY GET SO THAT SHOULD DO IT.
MEETINGS AGAIN THANK YOU VERY
MUCH